im politischen berlin mein kollege
erhard schärfe ist dort ein thema in der
bundestagsdebatte gleich der bundeswehr
einsatz in mali alles weitere jetzt von
erhard scherfer
vielen dank michael sah ja wir sind auf
der schlussgerade von zwei
sitzungswochen in folge nächste woche
dann mal keine ausschüsse kein plenum
aber in der woche danach ist dann die
sogenannte haushaltswoche da geht es um
viele zahlen um viel geld und um viele
etat serviert dann werden der politische
vorhaben also in geld quasi umgesetzt
und dann wird es unter anderem auch
wahrscheinlich um das sogenannte
sondervermögen gehen für die bundeswehr
die bekannten 100 milliarden da wirken
die heutigen tagesordnungspunkte zum
thema bundeswehr fast schon ein klein
wenig wie alltag sind sie aber nicht
denn es geht wie schon michael sei eben
gesagt hat unter anderem um die
bundeswehreinsätze in mali aber auch
ideen in libanon und da gibt es eine
ganze menge zusammenhänge wenn man das
ganze mal bei licht betrachtet um
darüber wollen wir jetzt schon mal reden
und zwar mit simpler der
parlamentarischen staatssekretärin bei
der bundesverteidigungsminister rinn und
sie kommt aus der spd-fraktion guten
morgen hin und ali al dailami ist bei
uns der stellvertretende vorsitzende der
linksfraktion zugleich deren
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher auch
einen schönen guten morgen frau
müller die vor ein paar wochen haben wir
noch den diskussionen darüber gehabt die
das die bundeswehreinsätze in mali
möglicherweise ganz aufgehoben werden
jetzt ist es so dass die eu mission an
der die bundeswehr beteiligt ist sich
aus mali quasi zurückzieht sie wird
halbiert man wechselt in den niger als
haupt stationierung punkt und die un
mission an der die bundeswehr beteiligt
war wenn die bundeswehr so anzahl der
bundeswehr soldaten sogar erhöhen also
ein ganz anderer verlauf als die
diskussionen sich anfang des jahres zu
entwickeln schien warum das ganze
wir haben heute eher maria im prinzip
ein mandat was 3 soll ich ist ja einmal
den ausbildungsteil werden den
beratungstag für mali und wir haben dann
die die ausbildung der spezialkräfte in
emea das finden wir auch schon eine
ganze weile durch und es seit einigen
jahren der mandatierung es wichtig beim
user ein so verlässlicher partner ist
und wir dort sehen dass das was dort
durchgeführt wird tatsächlich einen
effekt hat und ab hof gekommen ist
wollen wir den fall unbedingt fortführen
und wir wollen die ausbildung der
malischen streitkräfte aussetzen und
erst wenn die gegebenheiten sich
verändert haben dann muss der bundestag
entscheiden ob wir die ausbildung da
wieder aufnehmen dürfte aber so weit ist
dieser teil auf jeden fall beendet und
bei - man muss man sagen als minister
gesagt dass die un-mission haben jetzt
soll die abkürzung durch allen ganz so
präsent wie bei ihm bei - man ist es ja
so dass wir dort insbesondere da sind um
die zivilbevölkerung zu schützen
auftritt der vereinten nationen auch um
beispielsweise die die führung für des
world food programms abzusichern oder
auch um die verteilzentren abzusichern
so dass dazu mindestens noch ein
gewisses maß an schutz und auch an
entwicklungshilfe zustande kommt wenn
ich das bild bemühen darf - meist das
einzige was den intensivpatienten war
die danach am leben hält beziehungsweise
anschluss bieten kann für die
zivilbevölkerung al dailami wir kennen
die position der linken zu
auslandseinsätzen der bundeswehr auch
zur bundeswehr im allgemeinen und
besonderen aber frau müller hat ja eben
noch mal gesagt es geht um den schutz
der zivilbevölkerung in mali unter
anwalt unter anderem dass was spricht
dagegen diese mission fortzusetzen aus
ihrer sicht wir reden jetzt über die
un-mission man muss erst mal feststellen
also wo frau müller absolut recht hat
ist natürlich das teil der mission auch
die absicherung von hilfslieferungen und
ähnliches ist in diesem punkt
hat sie das richtig dargestellt unser
problem ist bei diesem einsatz man muss
konstatieren dass er eigentlich
gescheitert ist wenn man die anderen
zielpunkte sich vergegenwärtigt also man
redet davon auch im antragstext unter
punkt 3 heute dass man die staatliche
autorität in mali wiederherstellen will
aber auch dem friedensschluss zwischen
der damaligen malischen regierung und
rebellengruppen von algier 2015 umsetzen
will das problem ist wir haben seitdem
zwei putts regierung in mali gehabt da
frage ich mich was will man da wieder
herstellen als statische autorität und
die unterzeichner des friedensabkommens
von algier die sind neben der malischen
regierung die weggeputscht oder auch
nicht mehr rad die zweite zweite
unterzeichner wurde ermordet die dritte
gruppe ist mittlerweile aktiv mit der al
qaida und beteiligt sich an drogen und
menschenhandel und das ist höchst
problematisch zumal das auch der
verlustreichste 1 der verlustreichsten
einsätze seit nur einen einsatz damals
im koreakrieg es mit über 270 toten und
wenn ich das im verhältnis setze dann
glaube ich und kommen wir auch zu dem
schluss dass das völlig
unverhältnismäßig ist man das leben
unserer soldaten soldaten dort enorm
riskieren weil die ganze sache zone
desolat ist mittlerweile und wir ein
trip nach dem anderen erleben und das
ist ein großes problem zentraler punkt
der anspricht liebe auch wenn man sich
in der vorbereitung damit beschäftigt
irgendwie das natürlich die frage ist
wer ist eigentlich der ansprechpartner
in mali klar es gibt im moment im
militär eine übergangsregierung aber was
sie will ist relativ uneindeutig sie
haben sich jetzt mit den franzosen
angelegt deshalb die franzosen sich im
sommer und zumindest aus dem teil der
mission auch zurückziehen werden hat man
überhaupt noch gibt es noch die
legitimation die diese mission am anfang
hat es das ist ja genau der punkt der
auch hier angesprochen nur den weg den
sie jetzt auch unterstreichen dass wir
deswegen die ausbildung der malischen
streitkräfte aussetzen weil der
europäischen trainingsmission wir
beraten heute oder beschließen auf 2
-emissionen einmal die trainingsmission
die im prinzip kasse die billigen
filmische streitkräfte umfasste das wird
ausgesetzt und gleichzeitig haben wir
eine mission der vereinten nationen die
eben nicht die
kapazitive linken passt sondern schutz
der zivilbevölkerung nicht ich teile das
dass die sahelzone wirklich auch in
einem kritischen punkt ist und für mich
ist das genau das argument dann dort zu
bleiben was passiert wenn man wenn man
wenn wir dort jetzt auch noch abziehen
auch mit minus x das haben wir ja in
vielen orten der welt gesehen muss dann
eben die stabilität und sicherheit
komplett zusammen richtung deswegen
beteiligt ist dass im moment der
richtige dass der dass die situation
kritisch ist und man trotzdem dort
bleiben muss ein weiterer punkt der
angesprochen wurde zum schutz der
soldaten soldaten ist es deswegen im
mandatstext explizit auch aufgenommen
worden mit der luft nach unterstützung
weil wir weil wir auch aus sicht des
bmvbs natürlich sehr klar wissen dass
die luftunterstützung durch die
französische kampfhubschrauber nicht
mehr so gegeben sein wird aufgrund des
abzuges den die französischen anteile
vollziehen werden und dementsprechend
muss dafür gesorgt werden dass die luft
nach unterstützung beziehungsweise
schutz komponente gegeben ist dafür
haben wir ein bisschen zeit aber eben
auch noch eine ganze menge hausaufgaben
zu machen ist denn da ansatzweise klar
wie diese lücke ich sag jetzt mal
gestopft werden soll im
bundesverteidigungsministerium hat
appelliert dass die vereinten nationen
dar aktiver sein müssen die
bundesverteidigungsminister man hat ja
deutlich gemacht dass tief dass die
vereinten nation aktiver sein müssen und
wir wir müssen das haben wir deswegen
auch so im mandatstext aufgenommen dass
es aufgabe auch der organisation ist
wohl wissen dass die organisation
natürlich auch aus den mitgliedstaaten
besteht wir haben keine eigene fähigkeit
die wir einbringen könnte in
dementsprechend müssen andere
mitgliedstaaten köpfe diese fähigkeit
der franzosen situieren wir wissen dass
es viele gespräche gibt mit den
niederländern insbesondere und dass es
dann eben etwas was die internationale
gemeinschaft gemeinsam stellen muss wenn
mal ihr so wichtig ist was ja durch die
vereinten nationen und die
mitgliedstaaten dann auch so geteilt
wird gibt es herr alter lamine
alternative zu dem was vor müller sagt
und was auch die un-mission angeht wenn
man den blick richten will auf eine
relative stabile lage im land wenn man
einen blick richten will auf den schutz
der zivilbevölkerung sehen sie
alternativen erst einmal so das problem
ist ja erst mal dass man immer glaubt
man müsse mit militärischen mitteln
aktiv sein um wie hier behauptet wird
und auch um hilfsgüter und ähnliches
abzusichern bis zum gewissen grad kann
das auch funktionieren das problem ist
aber dass wir erleben dass das gezeigt
hat ist diese militärischen
interventionen um militärische beihilfe
ist gescheitert weil wir wie gesagt
einen witz nach dem anderen haben und
will noch eins zu denken geben haben
eben schon erläuterte sie haben den
punkt haben wir verstanden milliarden
die alternative ist diese äußere
einmischung die einhergeht ist ja eine
einmischung die stattfindet ich will nur
daran erinnern diese einsätze sind alle
in folge französischer vormals gelaufene
einsätze die beendet worden sind
stichwort verwaltet die mission und
frankreich schaut dort einfach
ökonomische interessen die sich aus
ihrer sicht legitim meinen zur
verfolgung zu wollen und das hat die
lage dem er die stabilisiert und ich
glaube und bin fest davon überzeugt dass
die menschen dort und die regierung dort
wenn man sie alleine ihre probleme und
ihre kulturellen eigenheiten und die
lösungs prozesse die sie selbst
entwickeln können wenn man sie wirklich
lässt dass sie dann es überhaupt eine
chance bekommt zu frieden schließen
bekomme ich nur ein beispiel in die
malische regierung hat jetzt
friedensverhandlungen angenommen und
angefangen mit rebellengruppen wo die
franzosen sich vorher geweigert haben
auch nur mit ihnen zu sprechen ich will
sagen das kann nur dazu führen diese
gespräche dass wir frieden finden mit
denen die dort an der macht sind und nur
das führt dazu dass die lage wieder
stabilisiert wird alles andere ist doch
gescheitert und deshalb dort muss
verhandelt werden man muss anerkennen
dass dort die an der macht sind die
verhandlungen führen und das ist das was
wir akzeptieren und anerkennen müssen
und zu allerletzt das beispiel warum man
dort ist gilt ja dann eigentlich für so
viele länder auf dieser welt da frage
ich mich wir müssen ja dann mit der
bundeswehr wie überall aktiv bleiben das
funktionieren einer mali und der
sahelzone insgesamt waren sie direkt
erwehren ich hätte uns auch noch ein
punkt da war also
nicht nehmen den letzten punkt auf wir
sind nicht in jedem teil der welt weil
es nicht für jeden teil der welt einen
kleinen verein mandat gibt im rahmen der
vereinten nationen un ist wir sind dort
auf einladung expliziten auf wunsch in
zwei verschiedenen mandaten unterwegs es
ist ja nicht so dass geburten dass die
bundeswehr und die präsenz dort nicht
willkommen wäre im gegensatz wir im
gegenteil wir genießen dort einen
exzellenten ruf und es stimmt das nicht
alleine durch militärische mittel
frieden geschaffen werden kann ich hänge
einer solchen ideologie bei weitem nicht
an allerdings ist es so dass man eben
mit militärischen mitteln manchmal eine
gewisse atempause schaffen kann und auch
muss da wird eben dann
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch
gewährleistet werden kann ich glaube da
ist einfach ein grundsätzlicher dissens
zwischen uns beiden und man muss dazu
gleichzeitig zahlen das ist ja kein
kampf ansagt sondern es ist ein
stabilisierungseinsatz die dazu dienen
soll das aufklärung geschaffen vollzogen
wird und dass wir auch möglichkeiten zur
verfügung stellen dass die bundeswehr
dort absichert und eben nicht kämpft
weekend und auch keine anti terror
operation dort leistet und ich finde
dass es ein wirklich guter auftrag den
die bundeswehr dort leisten und ich weiß
wie gefährlich ist und möchte ihn dann
auch an dieser stelle nochmal
ausdrücklich danken für den dienst den
sie dort leisten ich gebe mir noch zwei
punkte mit auf den weg bevor sie
antworten weil wir wissen ja auch die
lage in der sahel zone ist unfair hoch
gefährlich weil unter anderem
islamistische terrorgruppen unterwegs
sind war er keiner sich wieder aus
bereitet sich von denen man eine ganze
weile aber zumindest regel andere
weltweit wer eher weniger gehört hat
sind russische soldat truppen unterwegs
die teilweise kooperieren wo man auch
nicht weiß auf welche sind mittlerweile
schon auf welche seite sie sich ungefähr
schlagen das heißt also wie sie ein
kompletter zurück zu rückzug der
un-truppen will jetzt da sind würden
doch mutmaßlich zumindest infektion zu
einem zum kompletten kollaps in der
region für das stylishe überhaupt nicht
weil es einfach feststellen erstens mal
wurde ja damals von den regierungen
eingeladen sowie ja gerade begründet
wurde diese regierungen sind nicht da
die jetzigen regierung holen sich
russland zu hilfe und begründen das
genauso mit den argumenten wie sie die
west geschichte zuvor geholt haben
deshalb glaube ich erst mal nicht dass
ein kollaps geht ich befürchte er dass
wir uns dort in einen wettbewerb gegeben
werden beziehungsweise die
bundesregierung wenn man mit russland
einerseits konkurriert im übrigen ist
mittlerweile auch in burkina faso in der
zentralafrikanischen republik das
spricht dafür einflusszonen und den
kampf darum aber auch china ist
mittlerweile dort aktiv mit enorm vielen
finanzmitteln und es sagt ihnen ganz
offen dass wir diese bundesregierung
diesem wettbewerb gar nicht gewinnen
können weil so viel geld wie china
investiert und so viele menschen leben
die russland bereit ist auch dort zu
opfern an den eigenen kräften das würde
die bundesregierung richtigerweise nicht
tun und deshalb können wir diesen
wettbewerb der dort stattfindet gar
nicht gewinnen frage ich mal fix muss
ich direkt nachfragen habe weiß nicht
fahrlässig da jetzt raus zu gehen und
dann beim russischen söldnertruppen
beispielsweise das feld zu überlassen
wir sehen doch im moment die wie
instabil die lage ist die sind doch
gekommen weil die dort aktiven die
un-mission aber auch heute als nicht
ausreichend
kabel gefunden haben das haben sie auch
sehr deutlich gesagt und sie
unterstellen sogar im moment frankreich
autos und ein zweiter versuch gegeben
hätte von seiten der franzosen noch
einmal die logik lehne ich ab wenn die
sowieso anfangen zu sagen wir kämpfen
dort weil wir die russen dort nicht raum
überlassen wollen wo wir soll das denn
enden mit verlaub und die islamistischen
terroristen war nicht vergessen von
gelacht
ich würde einfach gerne
um der argumentation 1 punkte gegen zu
setzen dort kämpft niemand also die
veränderungen sind nicht da um dinge zu
kämpfen zu erkämpfen oder irgendwas sie
sind da um aufzuklären um um die
zivilbevölkerung zu schützen um die
verteilzentren zu schützen und die um
die ernährungssituation einigermaßen
abzusichern und ich bleibe über dem bild
das ist ein intensiv patient wenn wir
dort jetzt den stecker mit - matschiner
wird der intensivpatienten wir wissen
nicht ob er mit - ma überleben wird aber
wir können mit sicherheit sagen dass er
ohne - sterben wird und ich glaube dass
es in punkt wenn wir dann uns auch
überlegen die salz ohne scheint zwar
weit weg zu sein aber letztendlich das
ist sind es zwei länder es ist an
algerien und dann frankreich will bis
die menschen auch internationaler
terrorismus dann bei uns sein könnte und
ich finde dass es uns alle etwas angeht
was in der welt passiert und wir haben
ein klares mandat durch die vereinten
nationen und auch immer eine eine
willkommen heißen durch das malerische
regime das sich wie sie sicherlich auch
nicht als legitim an ziehe aber
nichtsdestotrotz es ist nicht dass die
internationale gemeinschaft aus dem land
geworfen werden soll insgesamt dagegen
den willen der regierung oder der
bevölkerung wäre sondern das gegenteil
ist der fall schließlich können gleich
antworten damit schließt eben auch noch
mal eine frage an welche lehren
eigentlich muss man oder kann man ziehen
aus den gescheiterten einsatz in
afghanistan wenn man das jetzt vergleich
mit der lage in mali muss man da nicht
aussagen aus meiner sicht dass der
einsatz in afghanistan überhaupt nicht
gestellt hat wir sehen jetzt ja dass
erst der abzug der internationalen
präsenz dazu geführt hat dass die
taliban wieder die schreckensherrschaft
berichten die sie errichten gibt die
bilder die berichte aus afghanistan
erschüttert mich zutiefst
und wenn man dann anguckt was dort eben
mit dem vernetzten ansatz mit zum teil
mit kapuze die building mit auch mit dem
aufbau von sicherheitsstrukturen
geschaffen wurde heißt es dass für 20
jahre 1 ein relatives maß an sicherheit
gewährt wurde für die zivilbevölkerung
und für mich ist der einsatz bei km
keinster weise gescheitert aber nation
building also nun will er hat auch nicht
funktioniert ziemlich funktioniert nicht
funktioniert heißt es nämlich dass man
alles in bausch und bogen klein reden
darf man muss einfach konstatieren dass
erst der abzug dazu geführt hat dass das
land komplett kollabiert ist jetzt sind
sie endlich wieder also erst einmal
zudem zu dem argument dass wir dort
helfen und ähnliches faktor ist das doch
daran an dem was dort stattfindet wir
haben seit einsatz von - also der
un-mission eine vervierfachung der
terroranschläge islamistischer
gruppierungen die anzahl
dschihadistischer gruppierung hat sich
versechsfacht in der zeit und sie nutzen
definitiv auch das un mandat um sich
immer wieder zu stärken und diesem druck
auf zu erhöhen und afghanistan mit
verlaub frau müller da muss schon sagen
dass sich natürlich anders das wissen
sie auch der ist brachial gescheitert
dieser einsatz deshalb hat man sich im
übrigen zurückgezogen und im übrigen hat
man sich dort auch auf andere verlassen
nämlich die usa sowie in der sahelzone
auf frankreich und das ist fatal
jetzt können wir noch eine halbe stunde
weitermachen können wir aber gar nicht
welches plenum gleich losgeht und sie
müssen rein die ersten
tagesordnungspunkte befassen sich mit
molly was spannend eigentlich würde ich
noch über sondervermögen reden und die
zukünftige ausrichtung der bundeswehr
auch im hinblick auf solche
auslandseinsätze haben nicht geschafft
haben wir bald mal nach vielen dank dass
sie heute morgen dagegen danke frau
müller danke ihnen sehr
sie dürfen weg gehen hier weil sich auch
ein capitals aus weil sie auch reingehen
müssen wir schauen mal hier noch
indirekt ins plenum rhein wo die
bundestagspräsidentin möglicherweise
schon auf dem weg ist kann ich hier
heute aus der etwas größeren distanz im
moment noch nicht erkennen habe auch
noch keinen touren aus dem plenum da wir
sehen allerdings dass das plenum relativ
gut besetzt wird dem höheren im
hintergrund aber dem gong und das
bedeutet dass die bundestagspräsidentin
jetzt gleich da sein wird an ihrem platz
wie gesagt die ersten beiden
tagesordnungspunkte geht es um den
bundeswehreinsatz ärmer der un mission
in mali und das fordern die debatte und
die abstimmung über den
bundeswehreinsatz der im zusammenhang
mit der eu mission das ganze wird hier
namentlich abgestimmt werden aber die
sitzung wird dafür nicht unterbrochen
werden und jetzt denke ich kann ich rein
geben denn es geht los morgen die
sitzung ist eröffnet
morgen
wie soll es angenehm morgen
vorab teile ich ihnen mit dass der
ältestenrat in seiner gestrigen sitzung
darauf sich darauf verständigt hat
während der haushaltsberatungen vom 31
mai bis zum dritten juni
2022 wie üblich keine befragung der
bundesregierung keine fragestunde und
keine aktuellen stunden durchzuführen
als präsenztage nach § 14 absatz 1 des
abgeordnetengesetzes werden die tage von
montag dem 30 mai bis freitag dem
dritten juni
2022 festgelegt ich sehe dazu auch
keinen widerspruch dann können wir so
verfahren wir kommen nun zur heutigen
tagesordnung hier habe ich mitzuteilen
dass der tagesordnungspunkt
28 abgesetzt wird
ich rufe nun auf den tagesordnungspunkt
26 beratung der beschlussempfehlung des
auswärtigen ausschusses zu dem antrag
der bundesregierung zur fortsetzung der
beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte an der multidimensionalen
integrierten stabilisierungsmission der
vereinten nationen in mali abgekürzt
heißt das - mal über die
beschlussempfehlung werden wir später
namentlich abstimmen
für die aussprache ist eine dauer von 39
minuten vereinbart ich eröffne die
aussprache und als erste rednerin hat
das
wort merle spellerberg
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen vor
wenigen wochen durfte ich die
aussenministerinnen auf ihrer reise nach
mali und niger begleiten und eines haben
meine kolleginnen und ich dort immer
wieder gehört sicherheit wir brauchen
sicherheit von der regisseurin in bamako
sicherheit von der schriftstellerin
sicherheit von der
zivilgesellschaftlichen aktivisten in
sicherheit die frauen die ich treffen
durfte wollen und brauchen sicherheit
beim ausüben ihres berufes beim
einkaufen beim weg zum grünen und das
sicherheit kein ausschließlich
militärisches konzept ist das
diskutieren wir hier im hause seit
wochen seit monaten
aber wenn die frauen die ich in unter
anderem ingo treffen durfte 1 deutlich
gemacht haben dann ist es folgendes es
ist schwer sich sicher zu fühlen wenn
die welt um einen herum von terror von
original von organisierter kriminalität
bestimmt ist die sicherheit der frauen
der männer der kinder aller menschen in
money wiederherzustellen
auch das ist unser interesse
und das ist das mandat dass wir der
bundeswehr für die un mission - mehr
erteilen wollen unser engagement soll
weiter zur stabilisierung des landes
beitragen wir wollen helfen den frieden
zu wahren und menschenrechte zu schützen
und das tun wir nicht kritiklos und die
malische regierung zu schützen in
militärputsch verurteilen wir der
traditions- prozess zur demokratischen
ordnung muss weitergehen
aber in meinen gesprächen mit den
menschen in mali ist klar geworden dass
demokratische wahlen dass kritik an dem
militärputsch nicht ganz oben auf ihrer
agenda steht es ist und bleibt vorerst
sicherheit und das hören wir und das
nehmen wir ernst und
deshalb ist der wichtigste deutsche
auftrag in mali die umsetzung des
friedensabkommens und die wahrung der
menschenrechte
und unsere soldatinnen den unser großer
dank gilt unterstützen die einhaltung
dieser waffenruhe wir fördern
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen und helfen
die staatliche integrität
wiederherzustellen
in einem land das von terror und
organisierter gewalt geplagt ist das
höchst fragil ist braucht es diese
staatlichen strukturen umso mehr die un
mission will kriminellen und
terroristischen netzwerken in der region
dadurch auch den nährboden entziehen und
so schaffen wir wichtigen raum für die
arbeit von zivilem personal für un
personal für humanitäre hilfe die
dringend dort ankommen muss wo sie
gebraucht wird
das liebe kolleginnen ist also der grund
dank dieses einsatzes und dieses mandat
ist ein zeichen für neue verantwortung
eine antwort auf geostrategische
herausforderung wenn die französischen
truppen sich im spätsommer aus magie
zurückziehen dann sind wir dort der
größte truppensteller aus dem globalen
morgen mit 309 soldatinnen schließen wir
die lücke die die franzosen hinterlassen
gerade bei der rettungskette und dem
betrieb des flughafens
wir haben die nötigen
transporthubschrauber die benötigten
drohnen und diese sind für die umsetzung
des mandates praktisch nicht ersetzbar
und natürlich bedeutet der aufwuchs
gleichzeitig eine enorm gewachsene
verantwortung und diese tragen wir für
die menschen in mali aber auch für
unsere eigenen soldaten
denn was wir nicht haben und das gehört
zur ehrlichkeit dazu sind die konkurs
straube und die werden fehlen wenn die
franzosen abziehen und das birgt risiken
denn ohne die luft nach unterstützung
sind unsere soldatinnen hörer gefahr
ausgesetzt und gerade deshalb ist die
bundesregierung im engen austausch mit
unseren partner innen um diese
fähigkeiten zu ersetzen denn nur so
können wir den schutz durchgängig
gewährleisten und auch deshalb haben wir
die ausstiegsklausel im mandat meinen
vollen abzug zu ermöglichen wenn die
sicherheitslage nichts anderes mehr
erlauben sollte und natürlich muss ein
deutscher beitrag in - mal auch im
kontext der anderen akteure in mali
gesehen werden wir wissen dass russische
kräfte der wagner gruppe vor ort sind
wir wissen dass sie schwere
menschenrechtsverstöße begehen und dass
die militär unter mit ihnen
zusammenarbeitet und wir wissen auch
dass diese zusammenarbeit zugenommen hat
die gezielte russischen
desinformationskampagne die unseren
französischen partner kriegsverbrechen
anhängen wollen können und werden wir
nicht akzeptieren und
auch deshalb
wenn wir alles daran tut jetzt nicht zu
weichen als weltgemeinschaft ist es ein
anliegen die länder im sahel zu
stabilisieren und nicht der russischen
propaganda zu überlassen
mannis regierung ist dabei im russischen
geostrategischen kalkül zu verfangen und
darunter wird am ende die
zivilgesellschaft leiden und auch das
hat die außenministerin auf unserer
reise deutlich gemacht um auf die
zivilgesellschaft zurückzukommen ich
möchte mich für die frauen in die
menschen in mali einsetzen die gerade in
unsicherheit leben denn nur und darum
geht es am ende nur aus sicherheit
heraus fand sich stabilität für
demokratische wahlen entwickeln nur auf
sicherheit freiheit entwickeln
und wenn ihr hierzu beitragen können
dann sollten wir das tun
und das können wir durch die beteiligung
der bundeswehr an - und deswegen liebe
kolleginnen empfehle ich dieses mandat
zu unterstützen
merle spellerberg aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen hat die debatte
eröffnet die abschließende debatte über
den bundeswehr einsatz der vereinten
nationen in mali eine gute halbe stunde
wird debattiert dann wird namentlich
abgestimmt werden sie werden in den
nächsten minuten häufiger hören denen
die abkürzung - made steht für die
multidimensionale
integrierte stabilisierungsmission der
un in mali nächster redner ist johann
wadephul aus der unionsfraktion
ja meine verantwortung für diese region
die gefunden ist sie leidet unter
überbevölkerung unterernährung
terrorismus europa deutschland hat eine
verantwortung für diese region die
nehmen wir wahr und deswegen
unterstützen cdu csu fraktion den antrag
der bundesregierung dort wird heute
zustimmen
unterstützen damit auch die vereinten
nationen un in dieser weltpolitischen
lage wir diskutieren viele andere
regionen der welt hier im ausschuss oder
in den ausschüssen
natürlich auch hier im plenum des
deutschen bundestages
man müsste ja die vereinten nationen
geradezu jetzt erfinden wenn es sie
nicht schon gäbe und deswegen ist jeder
einsatz den wir gerade im einst im raum
der vereinten nationen machen ein
besonders wertvoller und es ist jeden
einsatz deutschlands werden die
vereinten nationen zu stärken es gibt
genug nationen die die vereinten
nationen schwächen wollen sie
unterminieren wollen eine eigene regel
ordnung aufsetzen wollen das ist nicht
unsere politik wir sind der
internationalen regelbasierten ordnung
verpflichtet dieser einsatz manifestiert
dass und deswegen ist es gut wenn es
eine breite mehrheit im deutschen
bundestag gibt diesen einsatz in mali
und in der sahelzone fortzusetzen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe da
noch einige anmerkungen zum verfahren
und zum inhalt unseres engagement für
die zukunft das eine betrifft das
verfahren meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und das wirklich den kolleginnen
kollegen passen wollen wir haben einige
zeit im ersten ausschuss
zusammengearbeitet schon normal in aller
ernsthaftigkeit sagen den mandatstext
haben wir zwei stunden vor der ersten
lesung gekommen wir waren in den
fraktionen in den arbeitsgruppen unser
gesamtfraktion nicht in der lage vor der
beratung des ausschusses
zu informieren wie dieses mandat unter
welchen umständen ford geben sollte und
sie alle wissen dass die ausschuss
debatte entscheidend dafür ist dass wir
alle fraktionskolleginnen und kollegen
darüber unterrichten unter welchen
obwaltenden umständen die
bundesregierung gedenkt den einsatz
fortzusetzen
das bundestags beteiligungsgesetz ist
kein bundes kennt erkenntnis gerade
gesetz und wir erwarten von der
koalition in zukunft eine an einen
anderen umgang mit dem parlament in toto
ich setze voraus dass auch ihre
kolleginnen ein interesse daran haben
fachgerecht informiert zu werden und ich
denke so was darf sich in zukunft nicht
wiederholen
das zweite
auch dabei könnte man klappt schon würde
nicht leicht die koalition verraten wenn
man das vielleicht sogar teilt bisschen
legten habe ich in ihren reihen gesehen
dass das
dass das zweite ist und das möchte ich
in aller ernsthaftigkeit sagen frau
spielberg ich kann ihre ausführungen
fast vollständig teilen das ist sehr
sehr erfreulich und das tun wir auch
gerne sie haben mit einem kurzen satz
die rückzugs klausel erwähnt die wir im
ausschuss im verteidigungsausschuss
vertieft haben und das möchte ich schon
noch mal dazu sagen wir müssen mal
wissen worum es hier geht
verteidigungsministerin hat im ausschuss
besagt dass ein vollständiger rückzug
unserer kräfte möglich ist wenn ein
ersatz der kräfte die die franzosen
jetzt stellen nicht gewährleistet ist
und zugleich wurde uns signalisiert dass
man etwa damit rechnet dass im august
ein abzug der französischen kräfte
erfolgt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren reden wir ernsthaft heute über
ein mandat das die bundesregierung
gedenkt schon im august wieder
vollständig zu beenden wollen sie
ernsthaft im august über 1000 soldaten
und soldaten aus diesem un-einsatz ich
hab was zur un gesagt zurückziehen hals
über kopf die un mit wichtigen
aufklärungskräfte vor kollegen sie haben
darauf hingewiesen sozusagen ohne diese
aufklärungskräfte zurücklassen ich kann
nur sagen was ist eine abenteuerliche
vorstellung frau lambrecht und das was
sie dazu im verteidigungsausschuss
gezeigt gesagt haben zeigt einmal mehr
dass die der rat fragte unseres
fraktionsvorsitz an den bundeskanzler
mehr als angemessen war so geht es nicht
entweder wir stimmen hier ein mann dazu
wo auch die vereinten nationen sich
darauf verlassen können dass deutsche
kräfte in dieser stärke
stärkste mandats kraft vor ort für ein
jahr verlässlich vor ort ist oder wir
stimmen den mandat nicht zu wir müssen
uns darauf verlassen können dass die
bundesregierung alles daran setzt dass
das mandat ein gehalten werden kann das
ist ihre hausaufgabe die geben wir ihnen
mit
ich will das in aller ernsthaftigkeit
sagen ja das ist dass das ist nicht ein
spannendes konstrukte kollege lechte das
ist kein spannendes konstrukt sondern
man weiß seit man weiß seit februar dass
die franzosen sich definitiv
zurückziehen und diejenigen die wie sie
sehr informiert sind über die gesamte
lage vor ort und das verhältnis zwischen
der malischen regierung und der
französischen regierung konnten auch
schon vorher davon ausgehen dass das
geschehen würde also das ist keine sache
die man vom himmel gefallen ist und es
wäre die aufgabe der
verteidigungsministerin gewesen sich
darum zu kümmern und darum müssen wir
jetzt auch diese zeit müssen wir nutzen
und da biete ich nur für meine fraktion
auch die zusammenarbeit und die
diskussion in den fachausschüssen und
auch darüber hinausgehend in den
nächsten monaten an wir brauchen jetzt
auch eine strategie für diese region und
das dilemma ist ja auch richtig
beschrieben worden frau spellerberg ich
teile das natürlich müssen wir weiterhin
die sicherheitspolitische voraussetzung
dafür schaffen dass in dieser region
insbesondere im staat mali eine
demokratische entwicklung stattfinden
kann eine soziale entwicklung
stattfinden kann dass frauen aber auch
alle anderen menschen sich sicher
bewegen können und da brauchen wir einen
erweiterten sicherheitsbegriff
vollkommen eindeutig natürlich dürfen
wir nicht zulassen dass die russen damit
wagner kräften einfluss gewinnen und
natürlich müssen wir den internationalen
terrorismus bekämpfen dafür braucht es
eine gesamtstrategie die viel fehlt
bisher und darum sollten wir uns alle
bemühen herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
johann wadephul einer der
stellvertretenden vorsitzenden der
unionsfraktion
signalisiert die zustimmung seiner
tricks seiner fraktion zum un einsatz
der bundeswehr in mali erwartet aber
auch eine gesamtstrategie für die
nächste zeit und darauf kann jetzt
direkt er wieder nils schmid der
außenpolitische sprecher der spd
fraktion
zunächst einmal bin ich der
cdu/csu-fraktion dankbar dass sie diesen
einsatz unterstützt das ist gut dass wir
in diesen fragen wo die bundeswehr ins
ausland entsendet wird möglichst breite
unterstützung aus der mitte des hauses
erfahren
ich bin aber etwas verwundert kollege
vage aussage zu dem mandat und der frage
eines möglichen abzugs der bundeswehr
denn umgekehrt wird ein schuh draus sie
wollen doch nicht ernsthaft als cdu csu
fraktion den einsatz fortsetzen wenn die
sicherheit und die medizinische
versorgung unserer soldaten liegen mehr
gewährleistet
das geht natürlich um ein abstraktes
bekenntnis zu einer un-mission natürlich
will diese bundesregierung wie auch die
vorangegangenen bundesregierungen die
arbeit der un stärken und insbesondere
auch bei einer der größten
friedensmissionen der un unterstützung
leisten aber wenn unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten in gefahr sind weil die
medizinische versorgung mangels
transportkapazitäten nicht mehr
ausreichend gewährleistet ist im
krisenfall dann müssen wir konsequenzen
ziehen das ist unsere aufgabe alle
parlamentarier für unsere bundeswehr
und deshalb gibt es diese
ausstiegsklausel in dem mandat sowie von
der bundesregierung
vorgeschlagen und vorgelegt und wir
bekennen uns ausdrücklich dazu dass wir
die bundeswehrsoldaten abziehen müssen
wenn diese sicherheit nicht mehr
gewährleistet ist
ich will aber auch deutlich sagen dass
der manie einsatz einmal mehr den engen
zusammenhang zwischen sicherheit und
entwicklung aufzeigt ohne sicherheit
keine entwicklung ohne
entwicklung aber auch keine nachhaltige
sicherheit und deshalb ist schon seit
jahren dieser einsatz der bundeswehr in
mali auch ein testfall für den
vernetzten ansatz denn die konfliktlagen
die problemlagen marlies in vielfacher
sind vor allem soziale
verteilungskonflikte verschärft durch
die veränderung des klimas in der
sahel-zone insgesamte sind ökologische
konflikte und es sind ungelöste
politische konflikte vor allem die
mangelhafte vertretung der jungen
generation im politischen system
verstärkt durch politische
fehlentwicklung der letzten jahre dass
auch in mali die regierung auf den
einsatz von milizen gesetzt hat in der
vergangenheit die ebenfalls schwerer
menschenrechtsverletzungen der
bezichtigt worden sind dass jetzt die
wagner miliz dazugekommen ist ebenfalls
mit schweren menschenrechtsverletzung
dass wale nicht durchgeführt werden und
wenn sie durchgeführt werden nicht auf
ausreichende akzeptanz
stoßen weil eben nicht alle
bevölkerungsgruppen
abgebildet werden die demilitarisierung
und wiedereinführung bewaffneter kämpfer
geht schleppend voran und der zivile
shooter auf dem gipfel von in schameder
im sinne von entwicklung der schaffung
von inseln der stabilität versprochen
worden ist geht auch sehr zögerlich und
schwerfällig voran also eine durchaus
schwierige
gesamtgemengelage wo aber gerade diese -
mission zentrale stabilisierungs
funktionen warmen und deshalb ist es gut
dass wir heute 23 tun im deutschen
bundestag dort wo es nicht gut läuft
nämlich bei der ausbildungsmission haben
wir den mut einen klaren schnitt zu
machen und zwar nicht länger zuzuwarten
sondern diesen schnitt heute und jetzt
zu machen nachdem die putschisten die
grundlage für die zusammenarbeit
entzogen haben und gleichzeitig bekennen
wir uns zur arbeit der vereinten
nationen zur stabilisierungsarbeiten für
- mag zur unterstützung des
friedensabkommens von algier und
natürlich auch zur absicherung der
großen und beträchtlichen deutschen
entwicklungshilfe die in maria weiterhin
gewährleistet werden sollten deshalb ist
für uns diese - sohn eine
die im sinne des vernetzten ansatzes das
richtige tut deshalb sind wir auch
bereit
fähigkeitslücken zu schließen sofern die
bundeswehr selber fähigkeiten zusätzlich
einbringen kann aber es ist eine
uno-mission deshalb ist auch die gesamte
uno in der verantwortung ausreichend
technische fähigkeiten für diese mission
zu entsenden und es ist eben nicht
aufgabe der bundeswehr und das können
wir auch gar nicht alle lücken zu
schließen die seit jahren beklagt werden
sondern das ist eine aufgabe der
gesamten weltgemeinschaft und in diesem
sinne ist die bundesregierung auch im
gespräch die lücken bei den fähigkeiten
für transporte
für den transport hubschrauber zu
schließen
wir wissen dass der prozess in mali
mühselig sein wird aber ohne bahnen eine
ausreichend
solide wählerregistrierung im vorfeld
warnen die auch neuen kräften die
möglichkeit
eröffnen sich an diesen demokratischen
prozess zu beteiligen ohne ein
mindestmaß an
demokratischen institutionen in mali
werden wie auch die zugrunde liegenden
ökonomischen und gesellschaftlichen
konflikte nicht lösen können das ist mir
ganz wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass der
ansatz den wir in mali farm nicht
aussichtslos ist denn mali hat auch
schon lange phasen demokratische
regierung erlebt wir haben eine
lebendige zivilgesellschaft wir haben
institutionen die man aufbauen kann auf
die man setzen kann und deshalb ist es
aller mühen wert von uns im deutschen
bundestag von der bundesregierung der
bundeswehr aber auch dem zivilen
engagement diese unterstützung für
dieses land über - arbeit zu leisten
ich danke all denjenigen bei der
bundeswehr und in der entwicklungshilfe
tätigen die sich weiterhin in diesem
land engagieren und selbstverständlich
wird die spd zustimmen herzlichen dank
nils schmid war dass der außenpolitische
sprecher der spd-fraktion hat auch am
ende mal gesagt erst für die fraktion
werde zustimmen das ganze wird in gut 20
minuten dann sein dass die abstimmung
hier in der west lobby eröffnet werden
wird aber vorher haben wir auch
regenreifen leute aus der fdp fraktion
unter anderem in sehr geehrte damen und
herren das mandat das sie heute zur
abstimmung vorliegt ist ja wirklich mal
bemerkenswert schon in den ersten sätzen
steht ja darin dass es vielleicht gar
nicht funktionieren wird und wie es
frühzeitig werden beenden müssen die
bundesregierung hat offensichtlich kein
vertrauen in das eigene mandat aber wir
sollen heute auf dieser grundlage schon
mal 1400 deutsche soldaten nach mali
entsenden die alternative für
deutschland wird das sicher nicht
mitmachen
und ich will mal zwei argumente
aufgreifen die von den befürwortern
dieses mandates des öfteren genannt
werden das eine ist dass wir nicht
abziehen könnten aus mali war ja ein
vakuum entstanden und das mag ja sogar
sein in dem winzigen teil x iks den wir
irgendwie kontrollieren da könnte ein
vakuum entstehen aber dieses argument
das können wir doch nur gelten lassen
wenn die bundesregierung uns ein konzept
vorlegt mit dem sich das perspektivisch
mal ändert dass irgendwann mal der tag
kommt an dem wir unsere soldaten aus
mali wieder abziehen können und kein
vakuum mehr entsteht ein solches konzept
bleibt die bundesregierung uns aber
schuldig so dass es heute im kern darum
geht 1400 bundeswehr-soldaten nach mali
zu schicken damit sie dort ausharren und
wie einfach mal das beste hoffen und
hoffen dass sich einer findet der die
luft nach unterstützung bereit stellt
das es verantwortungslos gegenüber
unseren soldaten gestimmten ein heute
und der andere punkt ja manchmal genannt
wird ist das migrationsbewegungen
anfangen können von mali aus nach
deutschland wenn wir abziehen würden
oder auch dass terroristen vielleicht
herüber kommen da gibt es eine relativ
einfache lösung liebe bundesregierung
machen sie ihren job kontrollieren sie
wäre ein wandert nach deutschland
schützen sie die grenzen dass es ihr
auftrag nicht der unserer soldaten
und ich will mal ein paar zahlen denn
zumal weil ja alles so toll läuft wie
man hier schnell ausschließen könnte aus
ihren reden die sie erhalten haben 2013
fing der einsatz an das stand mali auf
dem globalen terrorismus index auf platz
19 vier jahre später 2017 stand mali auf
platz zehn und heute steht mali auf
platz sieben des globalen terrorismus
index dieser verschlechterung konnten
wir nicht verhindern 2020 gab es 393
terror tote in mali ein jahr später
574 dass eine erhöhung von 46%
terrororganisationen in nord und zentral
wie rekrutieren so erfolgreich neue
kämpfer wie nie zuvor - meist der
gefährlichste un-einsatz mit 272 toten
zwei davon waren bundeswehrsoldaten wir
reden lieber ein land das dreieinhalb
mal so groß wie die bundesrepublik
deutschland und die regierung meint mit
300 zusätzlichen soldaten können wir
irgendetwas bewegen während gerade fünf
tausend französische soldaten aus mali
wieder abziehen ich habe einen vorschlag
für alle die meinen wir müssen da
deutsche soldaten jetzt hinschicken
gehen sie in die nächste kaserne
empfangen sie sich im g 36 setzten sich
ein helm auf und dann fliegen sie selbst
nach malibu lassen unsere soldaten aus
der nummer raus
nächster gegner für die fdp fraktion
ulrich lechte der außenpolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
dieser versuch des latenten vorwurf dass
wir leichtfertig soldaten in missionen
entsenden ist eine bodenlose frechheit
weil sich auf wochen und monate darüber
diskutieren
und der chronik warum wir das mandat zu
spät vorgelegt haben waren dass wir
darum gerungen haben die beste variante
in allen hier im haus vorlegen zu können
weil dieses mandat so schwierig ist
nein die schlechteste variante ist dass
sie überhaupt in dieses haus gewählt
wurden aber da müssen wir weiter mit
leben
den kollegen warten
möchte ich entgegnen
ich weiß es ist ein sehr sehr schwerer
prozess in der opposition die rolle zu
finden und ich bin sehr dankbar dass die
union auch heute diesem mandat zustimmt
und dass wir in vielen vielen aspekten
die wir momentan behandeln müssen auch
im auswaertigen miteinander kooperieren
und zu gemeinsamen lösungen kommen siehe
der ukraine antrag siehe die mandate die
unsere bundeswehr betreffen
und ist gerade die sicherheit der
soldaten wichtig wir wissen was dort
unten passiert und deswegen haben wir
alle möglichkeiten in diesem mandat
angelegt dass wir auch zurück zu
beordern können haben der
bundesregierung die möglichkeit gegeben
je nachdem wie sich die lage für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten im marli
entwickelt das ist der grund warum das
man dazu angelegt ist sie wissen auch
dass gewisse komponenten fehlen die wir
selber als bundeswehr derzeit nicht in
ausreichender menge zur verfügung haben
die kampfhubschrauber und wir haben
davon mehr das ist bekannt nämlich über
50 und s inhalt momentan nur 9 danke
herr brandner für den zwischenruf ich
weiß es selber 9 uhr einsatzfähig
ich meine ich muss zur kenntnis nehmen
dass wir 16 jahre verantwortung für die
bundeswehr leider bei der union hatten
das ist halt nun mal historischer
politischer fakt und wir müssen uns
jetzt damit beschäftigen dass alles zum
fliegen zu bringen so wie es der
bundeskanzler auch gesagt hat wir müssen
die sachen zum schwimmen bringen wir
müssen die sachen zum fliegen bringen
wir brauchen munition und das muss
ausgerechnet eine koalition machen wo
die grünen mit ihren großen friedens
anteil dabei sind und die spd und ihr
habt das nicht zehn bebaut wir als fdp
unterstützen das natürlich deswegen
brauchen wir auch die zustimmung von
euch für die 100 milliarden welche
überraschung ja deswegen die ganzen
politischen diskussionen können wir uns
hier im haus schenken wenn wir nicht den
realitäten und stellen die realität ist
dass wir plötzlich einen stopp plötzlich
wir haben ein aggressor an der ostflanke
wie das so schön heute neudeutsch wieder
heißt und dafür müssen wir gemeinsam
streiten und die kommentare mal
weglassen da freue ich mich sowieso
schon auf die rede die gleich kommen
wird ich hoffe dass da eine kollege von
der spd dass entsprechend verfrühstücken
werden kann aber wir diskutieren hier
heute - mali als dem bis vor kurzem
wichtigsten einsatz der deutschen
bundeswehr im ausland und in mali sind
nicht nur
wagner
söldner aus russland sondern da sind
offizielle russische truppen
hätten wir deswegen aber jetzt gesagt
wir gehen dort raus dann hätte man ohne
probleme immer mal wieder 1 2 300
soldaten von russland in irgendwelche
krisengebiete entsenden können und
daraufhin hätte sich der westen seiner
verantwortung
entzogen das dürfen wir nicht machen und
damit dass hier auch mal gesagt wird im
hause
wir sind neben den problemen die die
franzosen mit der malischen regierung
haben die malische regierung muss
wahrlich nicht einfach ich war dabei wie
die außenministerin mit dem präsidenten
weiter diskutiert und gesprochen hat
aber wir sind ja nicht der einst das
einzige land auf gottes erdboden diesem
haus sich vorstellen könnte dort gibt es
viele kleinere truppensteller auch die
in diesem mandat mit dabei sind und die
sich auf uns verlassen und dazu gehören
unter anderem belgien estland litauen
und die niederlande als unsere
europäischen partner vor ort aber auch
große truppensteller wie bangladesch
burkina faso der niger senegal togo und
die elfenbeinküste
multinational und die verlassen sich auf
das großartige deutsche kontingent auf
unsere fähigkeiten die wir dort unten
stellen und dass wir mit ihnen zusammen
für die sicherheit sorgen und ich habe
in der letzten debatte schon gesagt dass
im jahre sich mittlerweile 30.000
menschen mehr befinden als zu beginn des
konfliktes und die vertrauen darauf dass
wir dort sind wenn am ende des tages ist
aber nicht mehr funktionieren sollte und
die grundlagen für die sicherheit
unserer soldatinnen soldaten nicht
gewährt ist dann hat die bundesregierung
mit diesem mandat die möglichkeit
abzuziehen und gleichzeitig haben wir in
das mandat geschrieben dass der
bundestag von der bundesregierung einen
bericht bekommt jeder zeit wenn wir das
wünschen wir haben also auch noch eine
weitere komponente
neben evaluierung die berichte für uns
alle als parlamentarier da drin deswegen
bitte ich um zustimmung ein besseres
mandat und
diversifiziertes mandat hat es lange in
diesem haus nicht mehr gegeben vielen
dank ulrich schlechte der
außenpolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion in der debatte in der es noch
einmal geht um die verlängerung des
bundeswehreinsatzes in mali hintergrund
ist eine un mission wir hören ali al
dailami aus der linksfraktion den
konnten heute morgen schon bei uns sehen
das interview mit simplem müller können
sie selbstverständlich war unsere auf
unserer youtube-seite auf unserer
homepage noch mal nach im rahmen des
einsatzes - mal in mali gegenwärtig sind
knapp über 1000 soldatinnen und soldaten
vor ort und heute nach neun jahren kann
man feststellen dieser einsatz ist
krachend gescheitert so gut wie keines
der verkündeten ziel wurde erreicht
schlimmer noch die lage nicht nur in
mali sondern in der gesamten sahel zone
ist völlig eskaliert und diese mission
entwickelt sich immer mehr zu einem
kriegseinsatz mit undurchsichtigen
folgen und für diese folgen tragen auch
sie meine damen und herren von der
bundesregierung die mitverantwortung
bisher als und 272 un-soldaten bei
diesem einsatz ums leben gekommen ist es
somit einer der verlustreichsten un
einsätze seit dem koreakrieg in den 1950
er jahren und seit beginn dieses
einsatzes sind tausende menschen getötet
um millionen betrieben worden
gleichzeitig haben sich die anschläge
terroristischer gruppierungen mehr als
vervierfacht doch anstatt sich das
scheitern einzugestehen und die
soldatinnen und soldaten endlich nach
hause zu holen wollen sie stattdessen
weitere 300 in das pulverfass mali in
senden ist sage ihnen dass es nichts
anderes als die fortsetzung des
bisherigen scheiterns mit ansage das ist
verantwortungslos und daran werden wir
uns nicht beteiligen meine damen und
herren
wenn man sich ihren antragstext mal so
durchliest dann steht da unter anderem
als auftrag für diesen einsatz unter
punkt 3 ich darf zitieren
unterstützung für die
unterstützung für die umsetzung des
abkommens für frieden und aussöhnung in
mali und b die unterstützung bei der
wiederherstellung der staatlichen
autorität zitat ende das ist deshalb
erwähnenswert weil es sich hier ja schon
erwähnt und das friedensabkommen von
aldi aus dem jahre 2015 zwischen der
damaligen malischen regierung und zwei
jahre rebellengruppen handelt ganze
sechs mal berufen sie sich heute in
ihren anträgen genau auf diesen
friedensschluss das problem ist nur
dieses abkommen hat mittlerweile
jegliche grundlage verloren denn es gab
zwei putsche in mali seitdem die 2 der
zweite unterzeichner dieses abkommens
wurde mittlerweile ermordet die dritte
unterstützergruppe wie davon gar nichts
mehr wissen paktiert mittlerweile mit
der al qaida und verdient ihr geld mit
drogen und menschenhandel und in
anbetracht dieser fakten reden sie auch
noch ernsthaft in ihren antrag davon das
abkommen von alt hier umsetzen und die
staatliche autorität in mali
wiederherstellen zu wollen meine damen
und herren von der regierung dass es an
absurdität und realitätsfremd kaum zu
überbieten deshalb kommen sie zurück in
die realität ziehen sie die soldatinnen
und soldaten endlich ab
und zu allerletzt
zweieinhalb milliarden euro haben sie
bisher nur für das militärische dieses
einsatzes regelrecht verpulvert sie
können sich einmal fragen wie viel leid
elend und hunger hat man mit nur einem
bruchteil dieses geldes verhindern
können danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit
ali al dailami für die linksfraktion im
verkehrs florian hahn cdu/csu
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher
von präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
richtig ist die sicherheitslage in mali
verschlechtert sich und sie ist prekär
und ende juni läuft das mandat der
vereinten nationen aus und kenntnisse
über eine substanzielle verbesserung
des freien mandats haben wir nicht und
aufgrund der französisch des
französischen rückzugs entstehen die
bereits genannten fähigkeitslücken und
nach dem rückzug weiterer partner
verbleibt deutschland als einzige
größere
europäischen nationen bei - man eine
perspektive
mit klaren zielen ist weder bei der vm
noch bei der bundesregierung zu sehen
und auch die beiträge von frau
spellerberg herrn lechte und herren
schmidt haben dazu nicht wirklich
beigetragen das vakuum das durch die
französischen dass durch den
französischen abzug entsteht wird in den
umkämpften gebieten vermutlich schnell
durch nichtstaatliche und terroristische
akteure gefüllt werden die
bundesregierung konnte uns auch nicht
schlüssig darlegen wie die
terrorbekämpfung zukünftig durchgeführt
werden soll folglich wird diese
gefährliche mission noch gefährlicher
werden das mandat versucht deswegen
lücken
vorrangig durch ein mehr an personal zu
schließen diese generieren aber nicht
ein mehr an fähigkeiten für die mission
sie sind auch nicht ausreichend um die
sicherheitslage in der region zu
verbessern beziehungsweise die
politischen ziele des einsatzes
tatsächlich zu erreichen und die muss
deswegen feststellen die mission hat
keinen ziel zustand keine realistische
bewertung des machbaren und vor allem
keine evolution der wirksamkeit der
mission und des bundeswehreinsatzes
der wirkungsradius der deutschen
soldaten für die zentrale aufgabe den
schutz der zivilbevölkerung wird auf das
umfeld des campus und entsprechend
begrenzt seien und weiterhin frage ich
mich für wen die aufklärungsergebnisse
wirksam genutzt werden können wenn keine
wird mittel mehr da sind und niemand mit
diesen aufklärungs ergebnissen im
anschluss arbeitet
aufklärungsergebnisse für die unsere
soldaten entsprechend ihr leben
riskieren und die bundesregierung hat
sich aber scheinbar bei den vn und
anderen partner nationen nicht
durchsetzen können sie ist also nicht in
der lage gewesen die relevanz und die
perspektiven gegenüber dem partner und
zu erklären und deswegen stelle ich fest
dass mandate es schlecht durch die
bundesregierung vorbereitet und auf den
letzten drücker zusammengestoppelt
wollen die ausstiegsklausel es dafür
signifikant sie ist ein zeichen für die
schlechte vorbereitung die eigene
unsicherheit die fehlenden perspektiven
und absprachen und deswegen kann ich nur
sagen da helfen auch alle anderen
ablenkungsmanöver nicht wir fordern als
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
dass die roten linien für den einsatz
unserer soldaten fortlaufend bewertet
und im parlament berichtet werden und
sollten die voraussetzungen für einen
einsatz nicht mehr gegeben sein müssen
konsequenzen gezogen werden die
entsprechenden szenarien und planungen
müssen vorbereitet werden es ist völlig
uns antwort lich kolleginnen und
kollegen der afd das was sie fordern
nämlich von heute auf morgen über 1000
bundeswehrsoldaten und soldaten einfach
so abzuziehen das wäre wohl mit größten
mit größter gefahr für dieselben
verbunden und es wäre im übrigen auch
mit blick auf die sechs nationen die
sich dort verlassen und verantwortlich
aber ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich wir die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion stimmen nur
mit größten bauchschmerzen dazu
beitragen das mandat nur mit weil wir
verantwortung für diese region haben
aber noch vielmehr weil wir es unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten schuldig sind
sie bei dieser immer schwieriger
werdenden mission zu unterstützen
das geschieht zum schutze um den
geordneten rückbau zu ermöglichen und
die truppe dabei den verdienten breiten
parlamentarischen rückhalt zu geben
herzlichen dank
florian a csu und
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion nicht ganz zufrieden mit
der mandats beschreibung die
die verlängerung des einsatzes zur folge
haben soll letzter redner in dieser
aussprache pardon ist christoph schmidt
noch einmal spd-fraktion
werde von eur präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren lassen sie es
mich gleich zu beginn sehr deutlich
machen ja wir als abgeordnete tragen
eine hohe verantwortung für das wohl
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
denn nicht an dieser stelle für den
einsatz sehr herzlich danke
und vielen dank an den kollegen lechte
für die geduld als nachhilfelehrer für
die rechte seite des hauses ich dachte
ich müsste ist für die linke übernehmen
jetzt muss ich zu weihnachten haben auch
noch ein bisschen übernehmen es ist ein
un mandat und wir bewegen uns in einem
internationalen rahmen und wenn sie
genau aufgepasst hätten dann steht das
ende mandatstext oder wir haben uns die
evaluierung im koalitionsvertrag
vorgenommen wir gehen mit dieser
verantwortung sehr sehr vorsichtig um
und deshalb danke ich ausdrücklich auch
der bundesregierung dafür dass alle
anregungen aus den intensiven beratungen
der letzten wochen und monate in diesen
mandatstext jetzt mit eingeflossen sind
über den wir heute abstimmen dadurch
findet nämlich auch der schutz der
soldatinnen und soldaten die
erforderliche berücksichtigung wie
bereits erwähnt dimension müssen - man
hat mehrere säulen ist heute
friedensvertrag und als gesichert werden
dieser frieden war und ist
und dennoch ist diese friedensvertrag
das grundsätzliche gerüst für ein
friedliches zusammenleben
es ist bei seinen häufigen frieden zu
schützen als einen heißen krieg zu
riskieren will
zweitens muss man die zivilbevölkerung
geschützt werden leib und leben von kind
und frauen und männern zu schützen und
präsenz von internationalen kräften ein
leben ohne angst zu ermöglichen das ist
doch ein sich selbst erklären das ziel
die meisten von uns wissen nicht aus
eigener erfahrung wie es ist in einem
unsicheren krisengebiet leben zu müssen
wir leben in sicherheit was wir aber tun
können ja tun müssen ist den menschen in
der salz ohne etwas mehr sicherheit und
angstfreiheit zu garantieren die
internationale präsenz im land wird von
der lokalen bevölkerung sehr begrüßt -
man genießt hohe zustimmung in den
regionen in denen muss man aktiv ist ja
und - und das wurde auch schon erwähnt
ist auch ein garant für die absicherung
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit und damit
für die zukunft im saal wir wissen alle
dass die menschen eine
zukunftsperspektive brauchen deutschland
ist ein willkommener und zuverlässige
partner das haus von ministerin svenja
schulze koordiniert in mali zahlreiche
wichtige initiativen und für diese
initiativen ja viele wichtige projekte
sind ohne ein mindestmaß an sicherheit
und das hat zwar später bei gewohnt
einfach nicht durchführbar mit unserer
zugesagt beteiligung - mal sorgen wir
dafür dass diese wertvollen projekte
weitergeführt werden
wir zeigen aber auch die gemeinschaft
dass deutschland bereit ist
verantwortung im rahmen der verein zu
übernehmen und hier nun die gewünschte
ansage an die ganz linke seite des
hauses internationale verantwortung
bedeutet eben nicht dass man der uno
einen kriegseinsatz unterstellt
mit der anhebung der personalobergrenze
unterstützen wir den ausgleich bisher
von frankreich übernommen fähigkeiten
vor allem im bereich der
sanitätsdienstlichen einrichtung al
dailami das nennen sie kriegerisch in
welcher welt leben sie denn finden sie
wirklich dass das die realität ist ich
bin froh dass meine realität anders
aussieht
aber wir formulieren im sinne unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten auch
bedingungen an die frauen und diese
ausstiegs 1000 was die bereits mehrfach
erwähnt damit auch die bürgerinnen und
bürger wissen worüber wir sprechen darf
ich kurz zitieren sofern während des
mandats zeitraums ein aussagen der
schutzniveau für deutsche soldatinnen
und soldaten nicht mehr gewährleistet
werden kann sind maßnahmen zur anpassung
des deutschen beitrags einzuleiten bis
hin zur beendigung des einsatzes dies
betrifft insbesondere die fortgesetzte
verfügbarkeit von luftunterstützung nach
dem abzug der französischen
kampfhubschrauber ich bin der
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht sehr dankbar dass im ausschuss
noch einmal sehr klar dargestellt hat
wie wichtig auch hier dieser punkt ist
sie hat in vielen gesprächen bis zuletzt
versucht eine lösung mit anderen
nationen zu finden und wird sich dort
auch weiter einbringen aber
aber und das sollten auch die kollegen
von union müssen die sicherstellung des
anteils der luft nach unterstützung an
der mission ist nicht die originäre
aufgabe der deutschen
verteidigungsministeriums sondern die
aufgabe der vereinten nationen
wir zeigen den vereinten nationen dass
wir zur verantwortungsübernahme bereit
sind aber wir ziehen zum schutz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten auch eine klare
grenze wir formulieren einen klaren
arbeitsauftrag an die uno und ich gehe
davon aus er dr war dass wir uns da
einig sind sie haben über die uno
gesprochen die uno ist bestimmt nicht
perfekt aber sie ist das beste mittel
zum multinationalen konfliktbeilegung
dass wir haben und es liegt an den
einzelnen nationen dass wir die uno
verbessern
lassen sie uns durch die zustimmung zum
veränderten mandat - man signalisieren
dass deutschland bereit ist seinen teil
zur stärkung der internationalen
zusammenarbeit beizutragen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
ich schließe die aussprache wir kommen
zur abstimmung über die
beschlussempfehlung des auswärtigen
ausschusses zu dem antrag der
bundesregierung zur fortsetzung der
beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte an der multidimensionalen
integrierten stabilisierungsmission der
vereinten nationen in mali der ausschuss
empfiehlt in seiner beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache
1878 dem antrag der bundesregierung auf
drucksache 1761 anzunehmen wir stimmen
über die beschlussempfehlung namentlich
ab die abstimmung erfolgt in der west
lobby sie haben zur abgabe ihrer stimme
nach eröffnung der abstimmung 20 minuten
zeit
ich bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer die vorgesehenen plätze
einzunehmen
ich höre gerade die plätze an den uhren
sind besetzt das ist damit der fall ich
eröffne die namentliche abstimmung über
die beschlussfassung auf drucksache
1878 die abstimmung zonen werden um
10 uhr fünf
geschlossen das bevorstehende ende der
namentlichen abstimmung wird ihnen dann
rechtzeitig bekannt gegeben
so und jetzt können wir meine damen und
herren einen blick in die sogenannte
weste lobby werfen wo die abstimmung ja
schon bereitstehen wir sind im moment
noch mit einem blick in den plenarsaal
der sich jetzt hier langsam
die abgeordneten ist strömen nach
draußen um ihre stimmkarten entsprechend
einzuwerfen ob sie der mission zustimmen
wollen oder nicht jetzt haben wir zum
ersten mal beziehungsweise oder können
ihn auch noch mal deutlich zeigen der
vorteil von pandemie vorkehrungen denn
das ist ja der hintergrund dass sich
abstimmung in der west logi stattfindet
dass man ich wollte wie viele es früher
gang und gäbe und üblich war die
abstimmung hier vorne im plenarsaal
stattgefunden haben wo die abstimmungs
uhren aufgebaut waren der vorteil ist
dass die abgeordneten jetzt 20 minuten
zeit haben abzustimmen draußen hier
drinnen im plenarsaal in dem wir jetzt
auch gleich wieder zurückkehren können
die debatte aber weitergehen kann
plenumssitzung denn jetzt geht es um den
nächsten
bundeswehreinsatz und diesmal geht es um
die eu mission
und da geht es um ausbildung beratung
und training die wie gesagt wird jetzt
weiter diskutiert hier im plenum ein
echter blogger ist die erste rednerin
dazu
auf den weg zu bringen das war ja auch
der hintergrund der 2013 begonnen
europäischen ausbildungsmission für das
malische militär eine sicherheitssektor
reform muss aber immer mehr sein als nur
training von polizei oder militär gut
governance rechtsstaatlichkeit und
politische kontrolle gehören zwingend
dazu
leider zu wenig passiert stattdessen hat
die korrupte vorgängerregierung in mali
das vertrauen der menschen verspielt aus
der immer größer gewordenen
unzufriedenheit ist an die militär
runter über einen putsch an die macht
gekommen hat wahlen abgesagt und denkt
trotz zahlreicher verhandlungen
drohungen und sanktionen nicht daran
sich an den vereinbarten übergangsphase
zur demokratie zu halten gleichzeitig
arbeitet sie mit russischen söldner und
truppen zusammen die sicherlich in
erster linie menschenrechte frieden und
sicherheit für die menschen in mali zum
ziel haben ende märz kam es in der
kleinstadt nur raten der südlichen
region im opti zu einem massaker unter
beteiligung malischer und wahrscheinlich
auch russischer truppen die vereinten
nationen sprechen von 500 toten die
meisten zivilistinnen bis jetzt erhalten
un ermittlerinnen keinen zugang zu nova
das ist völlig inakzeptabel die vorfälle
müssten schonungslos aufgeklärt und die
verantwortlichen zur rechtlichen
die präsenz russischer sollten das
offensichtlich teil einer russischen
strategie den eigenen einfluss in afrika
auszuweiten so kann unsere
schlussfolgerungen aber auch nicht sein
dass wir einfach abhauen wenn irgendwo
ein russischer sommer auftaucht aber
eine militär unter die so eng mit
russischen truppen und söldner
kooperiert reformen verweigert und immer
wieder menschenrechte missachtet und
damit die grundlage unserer kooperation
der letzten jahre de facto komplett
infrage stellt die können werden und
dürfen wir nicht weiter unterstützen
und deshalb wird mit diesem mandat die
ausbildung beendet eine fortsetzung wäre
unverantwortbar gleichzeitig werden wir
den druck auf die malische militär unter
weiter hochhalten den vereinbarten
friedensprozess fortzusetzen setzen und
endlich fortschritte auf dem weg zur
demokratie zu machen auch zu diesem
zweck und um ein lagebild vor ort zu
erhalten bleiben ein paar wenige
soldatinnen in warmer der tat taucht im
mandat im operationsgebiet nicht mehr
auf wie in den vergangenen jahren das
ist ein land in dem die
menschenrechtssituation furchtbar ist
und das von der demokratie noch deutlich
weiter entfernt ist als man
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ganz
anders zu bewerten ist unser engagement
in die scheer wir nicht nur die
ausbildung der spezialkräfte wie geplant
fortsetzen und in den nächsten monaten
abschließen werden sondern im anschluss
wollen wir weiter miteinander darüber
beraten welche bedarfe sie selbst sehen
und wie wir sie dabei unterstützen
können hier wird noch einmal deutlich
ausbildung ist eben nicht gleich
ausbildung so richtig es ist den tschad
auszuschließen und die ausbildung des
malischen militärs umgehend zu stoppen
so richtig ist es für eine echte und
effektive sicherheitssektor reform in
diese weiter zu machen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen gerade
die stimmen die auch in der
vergangenheit
berechtigterweise auf die schwächen der
mission in mali hingewiesen haben warnen
uns heute vor einem vollständigen abzug
vielmehr müssen wir jetzt endlich die
gelegenheit ergreifen und auch aus den
fehlern der vergangenheit lernen das
internationale engagement in mali das
land ist ja eines der ärmsten länder der
welt wie viele andere in der sache zu
einer auch leidet es besonders unter den
auswirkungen der klimakatastrophe er
lebt seit jahren eine ständige
sicherheitskrise das spielt die
zivilgesellschaft eine extrem wichtige
rolle gerade frauen und junge menschen
stehen dort mutig für wandel ein wir
müssen sie stärker unterstützen
und in zukunft auch gerade auf die
lokale ebene schauen wo es perspektiven
und potenziale gibt die wird zu wenig
hören und wo es verhandlungsansätze gibt
die wir deutlich stärker unterstützen
müssen und auch aus diesen gründen haben
wir vorhin in der debatte darum geworben
die mission der vereinten nationen nicht
nur nicht zu beenden sondern sogar
leicht zu unter erhöhen und dass es auch
hier in den gesamtansatz ein sehr
wichtiger beitrag
mein großer dank gilt den soldaten der
bundeswehr und in vielen zivilen
experten die sich in mali unter sehr
schwierigen bedingungen für eine bessere
zukunft des landes einsetzen aber auch
ihm sind wir es schuldig dass wir die
mandate kritisch und schonungslos auf
den prüfstand stellen vielen geht ja in
der molly debatten der afghanistan
vergleich viel zu leicht über die lippen
aus meiner sicht und ich denke immer
auch über das ende von mandaten sehr
viel nach und seit dem abzug in
afghanistan noch mehr wann ist ein
einsatz eigentlich endgültig gescheitert
wann es besser abzuziehen stadt zu
bleiben und wie geht denn ein
verantwortungsvoller abzug und welche
folgen entstehen dann aus dem vakuum das
wir hinterlassen als koalition müssen
wir in mandaten auf diese schwierigen
fragen antworten geben wir dürfen die
dilemmata nicht ignorieren klein oder
schönreden wie das in der vergangenheit
immer wieder passiert ist sondern wir
müssen die schwierigkeiten und
spannungsfelder benennen und beantworten
eine werte geleitete aktive
aussenpolitik sie wurden erstellt sich
nicht irgendwie durch wartet ab was
andere machen und dann heißt sie
herzlich mit dabei zu sein sondern sie
geht gemeinsam und proaktiv mit unseren
partnern voran und trifft entscheidungen
und kommuniziert sehr transparent
deshalb passen wir unser engagement der
veränderte realität in bar übernehmen
auch weiter verantwortungen der sachen
region wir überlassen russland nicht das
feld aber senden eine klare antwort auf
die präsenz russischer söldner wir
beenden in weiten teilen die
zusammenarbeit mit dem militär unter
aber verstärken unsere unterstützung für
die zivilgesellschaft und die vereinten
nationen für diesen vorschlag werde ich
um ihre unterstützung und daher die
zustimmung zum mandat vielen dank anja
boche gaben bürger mit ihren argumenten
warum die mission der europäischen union
auch in der nächsten zeit von
bundeswehrsoldaten begleitet werden so
wir werfen ganz schnell noch mal einen
blick in die sogenannte westen lobby wo
die abstimmung zur un mission zu der die
bundeswehr beteiligt ist nach wie vor
läuft noch ziemlich viele abgeordnete
die ihre stimmkarten einwerfen während
hier drin im plenum diskutiert wird über
die eu-mission in der sahelzone und da
spricht jetzt annette widmann mauz aus
der unionsfraktion
es deshalb schwierig und sie ist komplex
und wir als union machen sie uns deshalb
auch nicht leicht nach dem erneuten
militärputsch im mai letzten jahres
seine schnelle rückkehr zur demokratie
und verfassung in mali nicht in sicht
ganz im gegenteil die malische regierung
verschleppten übergang durch wahlen zu
einer legitimierten regierung sie
arbeitet mit russland und den
sogenannten wagners söldnern zusammen
die im verdacht stehen wir haben das
gehört für schwerste
menschenrechtsverletzungen im ural
verantwortlich zu sein die übergangs
regierung blockiert deren aufklärung sie
behindert die arbeit der internationalen
missionen vor ort indem sie zum beispiel
westlichen truppenstellern willkürlich
flugrechte zur aufklärung zur
überwachung und versorgung verweigert
schließlich erklärte das regime von
übergangspräsident gold erst vor wenigen
tagen den austritt marlies aus der
gruppe der g5-staaten und bezichtigt
jetzt den westen an einem mutmaßlichen
militärputsch beteiligt gewesen zu sein
maly geht seit geraumer zeit einen
eigenen weg das regime definiert seine
allianz neu und es geht immer mehr in
konfrontation zu frankreich und im
westen
während der gemeinsamen reise mit der
bundes außenministerin und ihrem
gespräch mit reuter wurde klar dass
molly sich in sachen sicherheit auf
russland stützt und auch dessen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff auf die eu
ukraine unter verbrecherische krieg
putins es davon nicht abhalten
manns enthaltung bei der abstimmung in
der un generalversammlung
unterstreicht einmal mehr diese haltung
sind also berechtigte zweifel angebracht
ob es in mali noch eine gemeinsame
grundlage und ein geteiltes verständnis
für die zusammenarbeit mit der eu und
mit uns gibt und deshalb ist
folgerichtig es ist konsequenz unser
militärisches engagement für mali unter
vorbehalt zu stellen es heißt die tür
wird nicht endgültig zugeschlagen denn
das würde erstens nur russland in die
hände spielen dass unsere westlichen
werte dort diskreditiert und das vakuum
schwach und korrupt staaten ausnutzt um
seine strategische einflusssphäre in
afrika zu vergrößern und zweitens würde
es dem system wettbewerb auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent weiter anheizen
und die spaltung in prowestliche und pro
russisch oder chinesisch staaten
befördern meine sehr verehrten damen und
haben das kann eindeutig nicht in
unserem interesse sein
auf der anderen seite
bleibt mit dem vorbehalt aber auch eine
perspektive offen allerdings unter
klaren voraussetzungen
unsere bundeswehr kann und darf keine
sicherheitskräfte ausbilden die
gleichzeitig an schlimmsten
menschenrechtsverletzungen beteiligt
sind und genauso konsequent es ist daher
den schwerpunkt jetzt der militärischen
ausbildungsmission heute marley bis auf
weiteres auf das nachbarland niger zu
verlagern liga hat sich nämlich als
verlässlicher partner für deutschland
erwiesen und wird als stabilitätsanker
für die ganze region gebraucht denn bei
unserem militärischen engagement im
sahel geht es zunächst um sicherheit es
geht vor allem auch darum die
grundvoraussetzung für staatlichkeit zu
schaffen und das vertrauen der menschen
in die staatliche ordnung zu starten
dafür steht der vernetzte ansatz den
deutschland vor ort verfolgt und der
neben sicherheit auch stabilisierung und
entwicklung zum ziel hat das erwarten
die menschen zu recht seien es die
beeindruckenden jungen unternehmerinnen
die wir in bamako getroffen haben die
studierenden an der universität wien
email oder die menschen in grau und
quallen die sich ein leben ohne angst
vor gewalt und mit perspektiven wünschen
für sie setzen sich unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten hin - mal und in
mali und sehr gefährlichen bedingungen
ein sie tragen mit ihrem wichtigen
dienst dazu drei failing states zu
verhindern und ursachen für flucht und
vertreibung zu bekämpfen ihnen und ich
will dass ganz ausdrücklich sagen auch
den polizistinnen und polizisten in den
zivilen eugh ab missionen möchte ich für
diese schwierige aber vor allen dingen
für ihre hervorragende arbeit dann
mit der deutschen spezialkräfte
operation gazelle hat die bundeswehr im
rahmen von heute im einen maßgeblichen
anteil am aufbau und der ausbildung der
nigrischen spezialkräfte die neue
spezialkräfte schule in tillya ist
ausdruck dieser erfolgreichen
zusammenarbeit wir konnten vor ort
selbst erleben welch hohe wertschätzung
unser deutsches engagement dort genießt
und meine damen meine herren das hat
auch gründe denn die deutsche führungs
und sicherheitskultur bindet die kräfte
vor ort aktiv ein dabei hat die arbeit
mit gerade einem geschlossenen
nationalen verband enorm geholfen und
unser engagement bei ausbildung und
training agiert auf augenhöhe es
gemeinsam mit den partnern vor ort
konzipiert und eng an ihren bedarfen
ausgerichtet darauf können wir aufbauen
obwohl nigrischen sicherheitskräfte
enorm von der internationalen ausbildung
und ausrüstung unter stützung profitiert
haben sind sie der zunehmenden
terroristischen bedrohungen alleine
weder quantitativ noch qualitativ
gewachsen gerade einmal acht
sicherheitskräfte kommen auf 1000
quadratkilometer land die regierung hat
es sich zum ziel gesetzt diese zahl bis
2025 zu verdoppeln ein minimaler
aufwuchs für niger aber eine enorm große
kraftanstrengung dabei sollten wir das
land nach besten kräften unterstützen
unser engagement in niger ist daher auch
nach beendigung der operation der zelle
eine gute investition in sicherheit und
in die zukunft des landes unter gesamten
sales region und aus diesem grund wird
die union der verlängerung und des
mandats unter reduzierung der soldaten
obergrenze für mali zu stellen
herzlichen dank
annette widmann mauz aus der
unionsfraktion und vielleicht auch
höchste zeit mal einen begriff ja noch
mal kurz aufzugreifen tm das werden sie
auch bei den nächsten rednern
gelegentlich immer noch hören müsste
eigentlich eu tm heißen steht für
european junior training mission und
bezeichnet also die mission der verein
der europäischen union in der sahelzone
früher auf marli konzentriert jetzt auf
die sahelzone und den niger
viele kolleginnen und kollegen im
deutschen bundestag hatten wir die
gelegenheit mal in mali oder niger
gewesen zu sein und sich die lage an
geguckt zu haben vor ort werde das wäre
das nicht konnte den dem empfehle ich
einen film den film timbuktu von
2014 preisgekrönt der noch einmal
deutlich macht welche hoffnungen die
menschen in der region haben welche
bedrückung welche berührungen sie
ausgesetzt sind wie dramatisch die lage
für viele menschen ist in mali aber
stellvertretend eben für die gesamte
region des sahel und das macht deutlich
wie dringend notwendig es ist dass wir
uns dort entsprechend engagieren und
viele halten dem entgegen das beispiel
afghanistan und sagen da hat es ja auch
nicht funktioniert und jetzt kannst du
ja auch nicht klappen ich finde so
können wir nicht denken sondern wir
haben in jedem einzelfall und
afghanistan werden wir aufarbeiten und
diskutieren die verantwortung darüber
nachzudenken was können wir tun aus
deutschland hinaus im gleichklang mit
den vereinten nationen um stabilisierend
zu wirken in schwierigen teilen dieser
welt wir hatten die situation das muss
man sich ja immer klar machen 2014 das
wir kurz davor standen das dschihadisten
am ende die macht komplett hätten
übernehmen können in mali das war der
moment wo frankreich mit kampftruppen
reingegangen ist wo - markt kreiert
wurde und wo am ende auch eben die
ausbildungsmission route über die wir
jetzt hier reden entsprechend ins leben
gerufen wurde wir leben oder wir reden
über eine eine region von großer
instabilität mittlerweile drei der fünf
länder des sahel wert von einer
putschisten regierung geführt und
deswegen ist es eine schmale
gratwanderung
alles zu tun was wir tun können damit
die region nicht weiter im chaos
versinkt aber gleichzeitig wollen wir
natürlich auch keine budget
putschregierung
unterstützen das ist auch die schmale
gratwanderung die dieses mandat
beschreibt dieses eu tm mandat wo wir
auf der einen seite sagen ja wir wollen
da bleiben wir wollen weiter ausbilden
aber wir wollen eben nicht soldatinnen
soldaten einer putschregierung ausbilden
und deswegen eben die fokussierung und
die
konzentration auf nigeria und deswegen
auch die mandats reduzierung von 600 auf
in den letzten tagen bin ich da im
verteidigungsausschuss vorbeigelaufen
und da gibt es ja diesen gedenkort für
die soldatinnen und soldaten wenn man
sich mal ein paar minuten zeit nimmt und
mal guckt dann sieht man eben wie viele
soldatinnen und soldaten aus deutschland
am ende auch gefallen sind in mali und
deswegen ist es notwendig dass wir
heftig ringen und dieses mandat und
deswegen erwarte viel habe ich das nicht
verstanden sie wären es vielleicht
selber gar nicht wissen aber es ist
eigentlich ein bisschen unter ihrem
anspruch an der stelle die verquickung
dort vorzunehmen und so versuchen auch
noch mal die verteidigungsministerin an
der stelle zu kritisieren natürlich ist
es unsere verantwortung bei jedem mandat
immer darüber nachzudenken ist es
verantwortlich für die soldatinnen und
soldaten aus deutschland können wir das
risiko dem sie ausgesetzt sind
jedenfalls so einschränken dass wir
dieses mandat verantworten können
deswegen ist natürlich richtig dass die
verteidigungsministerin und wir alle
gemeinsam mit diesem haus darüber
nachdenken was sind die voraussetzungen
für solche militäreinsätze und wenn sie
nicht gegeben sind dann werden wir
diesen militäreinsatz auch beenden
müssen
aber wir halten ihn eben für notwendig
und deswegen müssen wir es erklären
müssen wir den soldatinnen soldaten
erklären dass wir glauben dass wir
unseren beitrag leisten müssen damit die
region eben nicht weiter im chaos
versinkt nicht nieder nicht die anderen
länder der saale wo eben islamistische
gruppen ihr unwesen treiben wo
kriminelle banden herrschen wo wir niger
als transitland haben für waffen drogen
und menschenschmuggel und eben auch ein
rasantes bevölkerungswachstum
knappheit an ressourcen und
ernährungsunsicherheit und deswegen und
das würde ich dann auch nochmal für uns
reklamieren wie die kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalition auch ist es so
dass wir einen integrierten ansatz
fahren wollen dass wir verbinden wollen
das was entwicklungszusammenarbeit
ausmacht aber eben auch das was wir an
sicherheitspolitischen komponenten
entsprechen leisten können wir leisten
dort eine umfassende
entwicklungszusammenarbeit im gesamten
sahel wir unterstützen die justizreform
die unterstützten korruptionsbekämpfung
die unterstützten bemühungen zu den
trend dezentralisierung zur
effektivierung der polizei zur lokalen
konfliktlösung zur
vergangenheitsbewältigung
und zu extremismus prävention um nur
einige beispiele zu nennen die palette
könnte man fortführen wir sind also
tätig und damit wir dort tätig sein
können stabilisierend wirken können im
sinne der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
deswegen ist es eben nötig auch eine
militärische komponente zu haben dazu
gehört die ausbildung jedenfalls der
soldatinnen und soldaten der regierung
die dort demokratisch gebildet werden
das ist das was wir mit diesem mandat eu
tm tun und ich will es noch mal
unterstützen es gehören zwei dinge mit
dazu das eine ist der selbstschutz und
die fähigkeit zum selbstschutz der
deutschen soldatinnen und soldaten und
das zweite ist dass wir alles tun und
sicherstellen dass wir keine
putschregierung unterstützen deswegen
ist molly jetzt jedenfalls mit kleinen
ausnahmen nicht mit in diesem eu tm
mandat sollte sich das ändern weil wir
hoffentlich wieder eine demokratische
regierung auch in mali bekommen dann
würden wir im deutschen bundestag zurück
kommen und um eine mandats veränderung
bin vielen herzlichen dank
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
komme ich zurück zu tagesordnungspunkt
26 die zeit für die abstimmung
ist fast vorbei ist
noch ein mitglied im haus das noch nicht
abgestimmt hat der kollege schwabe gut
er hat ja jetzt auch noch zeit wenn er
sich ein bisschen schneller bewegt
dann können wir die abstimmung gleich
schließen dann fahren wir jetzt erstmal
fort
in der tagesordnung und als nächster
redner für die afg fraktion spricht
gerold otte
[Applaus]
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen letzten monat und jana das
militär in mali und in anderen
westafrikanischen staaten fünf mal
geputscht kurz nachdem hier vor einem
jahr das aktuelle mandat beschlossen
wurde riss im mai
2021 das militär in mali die macht an
sich der transitionsprozess wurde
gestoppt und die waren auf unbestimmte
zeit verschoben das regime behindert -
mal wo es nur geht und am vergangenen
sonntag mali auch noch seinen auswahl
aus der g5 zahlen verkündet seit 2012
truppen im land ein bewaffneter konflikt
dem bereits mehrere tausend soldaten und
zivilisten zum opfer gefallen sind
enthalten sind mehr monaten auch
russische seltener der sogenannten
gruppe wagen nach aktiv diese
unterstützt das regime reuters im kampf
gegen seine feinde und islamisten dabei
gehen sie äußerst gewalttätig und brutal
vor kommen bei der aktion offenbar immer
wieder zu menschenrechtsverletzungen
dann bricht der
menschenrechtsorganisation human rights
watch sollten ende märz der stadt
moralische streitkräfte gemeinsam den
russischen söldnern circa 500 zivilisten
getötet haben darunter auch einige mut
matschie die artisten
das alles führte letztlich dazu dass die
ausbildung somalischer einheiten durch
geothermie ausgesetzt wurde
halten wir also fest
das interesse ist einziger der leyen die
eigenen machtsicherung russlands
interesse ist die schwächung des westens
beide verbindet das interesse an hat
zurückdrängen das einfluss des
frankreichs und der eu in der region
was lässt sich daraus schlussfolgern
dass internationale krisenmanagement in
mali der aufwand stabilen demokratischen
rechten systems gescheitert vorschlag
zimmer schalteten afghanistan und
ebenfalls in mali hier wird immer
scheitern wenn ihr treffen von helfern
und geholfen im nicht übereinstimmen
es scheint daneben auch weil sie meine
damen und herren interessen mit
illusionen verwechslung beispielsweise
wenn sie versuchen standes kulturen
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
etablieren sollte sie unsere nationalen
interessen als teil dieser illusion
betrachten werden sie ein ums andere an
der realität scheitern
wenn ich von interessen spreche denke
ich nicht an die schwammigen linie der
bundesregierung und nichtssagende frage
die krisen verhindern konflikte
bewältigen frieden fördern oder ins
leere floskel wie die rede von einem
zivilen schub es geht um präzise
aufträgen unter den richtigen ansatz
vermittler methode erreichbar sind
letztendlich sind sie ist meine damen
und herren die unsere soldaten
vergangenen jahren wiederholt in
auslandseinsätze geschickt haben bei
denen eingesetzte mittel und methoden
eben nicht geeignet waren ihren
illusionen auch nur ein stück näher zu
kommen
wot mali kommen auch noch die räumliche
eingrenzung zu mit einem einsatzgebiet
von mali mauretanien burkina faso und
niger an gebieten mehr als zehn mal so
groß wie die bundesrepublik deutschland
ist die trainingsmission zu einem sammle
mandat für unterschiedliche aufgaben
unseren soldaten geworden meinte
vielleicht noch sinnvoll zusammenspiel
aber keineswegs zielführend diese
feststellung fällt umso schwerer weil
dadurch die bewiesene
einsatzbereitschaft der mut und die
opferbereitschaft unserer soldaten
letztendlich vergeblich sind ich möchte
hier aber auch der persönliche einsatz
unserer soldaten b & t mal hervorheben
weit entfernt von zu hause in den
familien in einem klimatisch extremen
umfeld und militärisch unsicher region
erfüllen sie dort mit großem engagement
den von ihnen und diesen parlament
überzeugen auftragen und dafür haben sie
unseren respekt verdient
man habe und es muss aber endlich
schluss sein mit auslandseinsätzen in
denen es letztendlich nur darum geht
irgendwie dabei zu sein und an der
vorgeblichen internationalen
verpflichtungen oder verantwortung
deutschlands gerecht zu werden das
vorliegende mandat lehnen wir deshalb ab
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
ich komme nochmals zurück
auf tagesordnungspunkt 26 gehe jetzt
davon aus der schwabe ist wieder
anwesend dass alle jetzt abgestimmt
haben
das ist der fall dann schließe ich die
abstimmung und bitte die schriftführer
und schriftführer die mit der auszählung
zu beginnen das ergebnis werde ich ihnen
dann später bekanntgeben
nächste rednerin für die fdp da haben
wir doch glatt noch mit geriet das frank
bsirske in allerletzter sekunde und
hauseigene abstimmungskarte eingeworfen
hat und jetzt schauen wir zurück ins
plenum da ist marie agnes strack
zimmermann am pult vorsitzende im
verteidigungsausschuss
deutsche soldatin soldaten nach mali
entsandt und ziel war und ist es heute
mali und seine partner in der region im
kampf gegen den terrorismus zu
unterstützen
zum einen verstärken die wii gerade
gesagt mit über 1200 soldaten soldaten
die stabilisierungsmission in den
vereinten nationen zum anderen haben wir
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
partnern malischen gerisch streitkräfte
ausgebildet in internationalen einsätzen
in denen die bundeswehr beteiligt ist
wird man öfter süffisant hinter
vorgehaltener hand na ja die anderen
kämpfen wir bilden aus meine damen und
herren das ist eine aufgabenteilung die
sinnvoll ist so lange unsere ausbildung
fruchtet und die zur ausgebildeten
soldaten befähigt werden das gelernte
anzuwenden ist auf dauer auch weiter zu
vermitteln train the trainer
aber die erfahrung der uns das
ausbildungs einsätze der bundeswehr so
gut wie immer mit einem besonderen
problem umgehen müssen wem bilden wir
eigentlich aus die entsprechenden
soldaten und soldatinnen als teil der
streitkräfte entsprechend in vielen
bereichen milde ausgedrückt nicht
unseren ansprüchen an eine armee
korruption fehlendes verständnis von
rechtsstaatlichkeit und menschenrechten
letztendlich gehen wir auch das risiko
ein dass die gelernten fähigkeiten nicht
in unserem freiheitlich demokratischen
sinne eingesetzt werden diese risiken
kennen wir und wir begegnen ihnen aktiv
indem wir gezielt die vermittlung von
grundwerten in die ausbildung mit
einbauen ja einmal wie gestaltet sich
die situation inzwischen schwierig und
seit dem putsch vor einem jahr erleben
wir zunehmend probleme auf
regierungsebene
es wurde hier genannt die
militärregierung fall berger zeitnah
neuwahlen der transitionsprozess geht
nicht voran und es wird offen und ohne
hemmungen auch mit russland
zusammengearbeitet überfälle massaker
menschenrechtsverletzungen und das ist
natürlich ein großes problem und diesem
problem haben in der summe eine weitere
ausbildung der malische armee
schlichtweg unmöglich gemacht und ja es
ist ein bitteres zwischenfazit im
zehnten jahr die malische regierung ist
nicht so kooperationsfähig wie wir das
wollen und die sicherheitslage wird
schlechter terrorismus problem wird
größer und das ist unser dilemma das
ziel unseres einsatzes ist definitiv
noch nicht erreicht aber ein voreiliger
abzug würde diesen status zementieren
wir würden platz machen für islamischen
terroristen und meine damen und herren
das würde auch uns in deutschland und
europa unmittelbar betreffen und wir
würden platz machen für mehr russische
streitkräfte die sofort das vakuum
füllen würden ich halte es deswegen für
richtig dass wir vor ort bleiben zum
schutz der zivilbevölkerung mit - aber
auch eben mit eu tm ali im raum der
salzstadt wir können unseren einsatz
aber nicht bedingungslos um jeden preis
fortsetzen und die ampel regierung hat
sich bekannt kein copy & paste mehr wie
die regierung zuvor wir evaluieren
diese einsätze und hinterfragen und wenn
die lage sich ändert dann müssen wir
auch das mandat ändern und ich danke ihm
ausdrücklich frau ministerin dass wir
vor ort und sein eindruck machen konnten
und dass wir deswegen diese ausbildung
auf nie sehr beschränken um die
demokratischen kräfte der region weiter
zu unterstützen und ja wir halten unsere
tür auch für die malische regierung
geöffnet 1 muss aber klar sein
mali hat nur eine chance auf eine
einigermaßen sichere und stabilere
zukunft wieder mit den übrigen g5
staaten kooperieren wenn es auf die
forderung auch der ecowas eingeht und
auch die unterstützung der europäischen
union auf allen ebenen wieder erlangt
der fahrt aus dieser isolation isolation
ist deutlich die achtung und wahrung der
menschenrechte durch alle staatliche
akteure und es ist schon ziemlich
unerträglich wenn es zu einem attentat
kommt wieder frauen und kinder ermordet
werden und wir nicht die chance haben
diese vorfälle aufzuklären und diese
aufklärung von
menschenrechtsverletzungen meine damen
und herren erwarten wir und eine
beendigung der kooperation mit
russischen truppen das weiß auch der
malische
verteidigungsminister das konnten wir in
einem gespräch an dem die ministerin
beteiligt war auch kollege orte und ich
haben wir ihm sehr deutlich zu verstehen
gegeben meine damen und herren wir
werden das mandat wir werden dem mandat
zustimmen aber lassen sie nicht die
letzten sekunden den soldatinnen und
soldaten die in curicó über jahre dort
eine tolle arbeit geleistet haben
menschen ausgebildet
auch familien begleitet haben meine
damen und herren die an schweren
attentat ausgesetzt waren vor einigen
jahren sie sind dort geblieben um ihren
auftrag zu erfüllen den wir hier seien
dieser auftrag ist beendet der wird
jetzt ausgesetzt und unser dank gilt
diesen soldatinnen soldaten von ganzen
tag
marie agnes strack zimmermann
vorsitzender im verteidigungsausschuss
zur european junior training mission es
geht um beratung ausbildung und training
von sicherheitskräften in burkina faso
in mauretanien und niger und eben nicht
mehr wie bisher auch in mali nächste
rednerin kathrin vogler aus der
linksfraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen mit
abenteuerlichen argumenten begründet die
bundesregierung die fortsetzung des
bundeswehreinsatzes im sahel die
ehemalige europäische trainingsmission
eutm mali heiß jetzt fähigkeit aufbau
der europäischen union im sahel mit
schwerpunkt nie sehr warum weil nach
afghanistan nun auch in mali das konzept
der ertüchtigung karren gescheitert ist
wovor die linke immer gewarnt hat
verfolgte im sahel von beginn an eine
postkoloniale agenda geprägt von den
französischen interessen am zugriff auf
die gold und uran vorkommen in mali und
niger und das sind die westlichen werte
über die wir hier reden während die
bundesregierung bis heute
unerschütterlich behauptet der
militäreinsatz in mali sei ein
wesentlicher faktor für die
stabilisierung der region stürzt doch in
der realität gerade ihren ganzes
propaganda bierdeckel gebäude mit großem
getöse frankreich sieht militäreinheiten
ab maly verlässt als militärbündnis g5
sahel und kooperiert jetzt mit
russischen söldnertruppen auch in
burkina faso ist inzwischen das militär
an der macht und der politische
militärische einfluss russlands wächst
auch dort in dieser hat das militär
jetzt schon zweimal versucht die letzte
prowestliche regierung in der region weg
zu putschen und es kommen täglich zu
schweren menschenrechtsverletzungen an
denen das militär beteiligt ist und
sowohl sowohl im niger als auch in mali
zieht die bevölkerung in massen auf die
straßen und fordert den abzug der
fremden truppen so warum tun wir das
wenn es doch so sehr ihrer sicherheit
dient dass die bundeswehr in mali oder
er ist die gründe dafür erklärt gegen
ein vertreter der zivilgesellschaft
militär ungefähr so die einsätze der
westlichen streitkräfte in mali hätten
die lage nicht zum besseren gewendet und
daher gebe es doch keinen grund
anzunehmen dass das jetzt anders sein
würde hören sie doch mal den leuten zu
dazu missbrauchen die eu staaten den
saal seit jahren für ihre zutiefst
menschenverachtende migrations abwehr
nie wer zum beispiel ist ein bedeutendes
transit land für reisende klar ebenso
wie für flüchtende und die militärische
grenz abschottung durch die eu hat viele
menschen wirtschaftlich schlicht
ruiniert in einem land das sowieso das
ernste der welt ist jeder zweite lebt
unterhalb der armutsgrenze oder 1,7
millionen menschen hungern infolge des
klimawandels verschärft und
dürreperioden diese nahrungskrise führen
konflikte um wasser und land und von
kabul bis nach niamey muss es doch
inzwischen auf den verboten militär
befürwortern klar geworden sei dass die
ausbildung von soldaten gerade ein
solches krisengeschütteltes land eben
nicht nachhaltig stabilisiert und schon
garnicht
demokratisiert meine damen und herren
eine zivile nichtmilitärische
außenpolitik die mithilft menschen in
krisenregionen eine auskömmliche
lebensperspektive zu schaffen und ihre
konflikte friedlich zu lösen das wäre
eine chance für sicherheit und
stabilität dieser aufgabe stellt sich
die bundesregierung leider nicht und das
machen wir als linke nicht mit
kathrin vogler für die linksfraktion in
dieser debatte des deutschen bundestages
über die beteiligung der bundeswehr an
der eu-mission in der sahel-zone es geht
um die ausbildung und beratung von
sicherheitskräften über mali hinaus
zum antrag der bundesregierung
fortsetzung der beteiligungsergebnis zur
un mission
der multidimensionalen integrierten
stabilisierungsmission der vereinten
nationen in mali bekannt gegen
abgegebene stimmen
648 mit ja haben gestimmt
541 mit nein haben gestimmt 103 4
enthaltungen die beschlussempfehlung ist
damit angenommen ich komme zurück zu
tagesordnungspunkt 27 und der nächste
redner für die cdu und das ist ein
ziemlich eindeutiges ergebnis
aber wir hatten ja im vorfeld würden
auch unter anderem von johann wadephul
gehört dass auch die unionsfraktion in
dieser mission zustimmen wird jetzt ist
am pult thomas mandl aus der
unionsfraktionen
vielleicht einsatz zu meiner vorderen
frau vogler ohne sicherheit gibt es
keine entwicklung das ist ein grundsatz
den sie leider seit jahren hier nicht
verstehen denn die stabilität in der
region ist unser ureigenstes interesse
rückzugsräume für terrorgruppen
organisierte kriminalität und
menschenschmuggler darf es vor der
haustüre europas nicht geben ein chaos
dort
den chaos dort bedroht nicht nur die
menschen im saal sondern am ende auch
unsere sicherheit in europa und deshalb
ist unser engagement in dieser region
nach wie vor richtig und wichtig und so
war natürlich auch der ansatz richtig
die malischen streitkräfte durch die
mission bio tm ali zu stärken seit 2013
hat die bundeswehr einen wertvollen
beitrag für stabilität und sicherheit in
der region geleistet und unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten haben ihren
auftrag dort professionell und
hochmotiviert erfüllt und dafür
verdienen sie unseren dank und unsere
anerkennung
[Applaus]
doch wie können wir können nicht so
weitermachen wie bisher denn es gibt
entwicklungen wie für uns einfach nicht
akzeptabel sind seit monaten fordert die
internationale gemeinschaft einen
fahrplan zu demokratischen wahlen vom
übergangspräsidenten güter leider ohne
erfolg da gibt es die offene kooperation
mit russland mit wagners eltern und die
weigerung massive
menschenrechtsverletzungen wetter dem
massaker in modra unter beteiligung der
un transparent aufzuklären die
bundesministerin hat bei unserem besuch
in mali diese dinge unmissverständlich
ein gespräch mit dem
übergangspräsidenten gut angesprochen
das war auch sehr sehr wichtig aber die
entwicklung ging leider negativ weiteren
den letzten tagen erfolgte dann auch der
ausstieg aus der g5 saal gruppe und
damit müssen wir feststellen dass sich
die rahmenbedingungen für das mandat
grundlegend geändert haben und deshalb
ist es nur konsequent dass
die beteiligung der bundeswehr an der
ausbildung der malischen
sicherheitskräfte nicht fortgesetzt
werden kann
trotzdem müssen wir einen weg finden wie
wir in der region präsent bleiben und es
ist daher ein richtiger schritt den
fokus von mali niger zu verlagern
liga hat sich trotz schwierigster
wirtschaftlicher bedingungen in den
letzten jahren zu einem stabilitätsanker
in der region entwickelt und die dortige
regierung ist ein verlässlicher partner
und an einer ernsthaften kooperation
interessiert
operation gazelle hat sich als erprobtes
konzept für die ausbildung der
nigrischen sicherheitskräfte erwiesen
und daher unterstütze ich ausdrücklich
dass die ausbildung dieser spezialkräfte
im rahmen des mandats fortgesetzt wird
und der eindruck vor ort zeigt auch dass
das wirklich in hoher professionalität
einerseits aber auch in einem geist der
partnerschaft
durchgeführt wird und an dieser stelle
eben auch noch mal herzlichen dank waren
die soldatinnen und soldaten die in
dieser mission dort im einsatz sind
die bundesregierung soll sich aber
gedanken machen in welcher form das
engagement der bundeswehr nieder über
das jahresende hinaus fortgesetzt werden
kann wenn die operation gazelle beendet
wird denn das internationale engagement
im saal und die stärkung der
handlungsfähigkeit der g5 staaten bleibt
weiterhin wichtig vor einigen wochen
reich mit der bundesministerin in der
region und ich komme zum schluss war
präsidentin die eindrücke haben gezeigt
dass die region für enormen weiteren
herausforderungen steht
nahrungsversorgung
bevölkerungsentwicklung aber auch die
folgen des klimawandels sind dort
spürbar und deswegen ist unsere
unterstützung weiterhin notwendig das
ist unser ureigenstes interesse
sicherheit und stabilität weiter zu
fördern und deshalb es ist richtig
dieses mandat fortzusetzen und wir
stimmen dem gerne zu verstehen
sagt thomas endl aus der unionsfraktion
mit dem auswärtigen ausschuss und
willkommen so johannes arlt aus der spd
fraktion
er ist mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe soldatinnen und soldaten
zweifel sind immer erlaubt wenn es um
die entsendung von soldaten in
auslandseinsätze geht für mich ist heute
ein bisschen in emotionaler tag hier
heute in diesem hohen haus mit zu
beraten über einsetzen haben einsatz
landen nämlich dreimal als soldat
gedient haben ich weiß allerdings ist in
war marco anzukommen mit einem berghaus
rucksack mit einer metallkiste und dort
mehrere monate verbringen und darum ist
es ja sehr wichtig dass wir ernsthaft
diskutieren ob und dieser folgenschweren
entscheidung ob ein investment ob ein
engagement in einem land gerechtfertigt
es aber nicht
dabei kommen viele aspekte zum tragen
sicherheitspolitischen erwägungen
außenpolitische ist unser engagement
vorausschauend umfassend und
multilateral ist der schutz der daten
gewährleistet aber auch ist der einsatz
effektiv oder nicht in mali engagieren
wir uns auf vielfältige weise nicht in
drei auslandseinsätzen wir haben gerade
über - immer abgestimmt dass leute
erneutes mandat wir sind bei euch hell
aktiv an der zivilpolizei mission und
wir engagieren uns eben auch bei heute
in mali und was ist der auftrag dieser
mission der auftrag ist was die
befähigung zur gewährleistung von
sicherheit gestärkt wird im sahel dass
diese staaten ihre territoriale
integrität selber schützen können und
das machen wir auf zwei weisen seit 2013
mit der ausbildung malischen
streitkräfte logistische kräfte auch
infanteriekräfte führer ausbildung und
seit 2008 zehn mit der operation der
celler seiner spezialkräfte ausbildung
im niger die einmal als kleiner einsatz
von kampfschwimmern in der wüste beginnt
jetzt eine ein nationaler spezialkräfte
verband ist dennoch im einsatz ist wir
müssen wir uns aber wenn wir uns für
einsätze entscheiden auch fragen
unterstützen wir die richtigen womit
nach stützen wir und erreichen wir
unsere ziele und da müssen wir ganz klar
sagen auch wenn nach einer neuesten
studie der friedrich-ebert-stiftung
84 prozent der bevölkerung die
sicherheitslage in mali als besser
empfunden als im vorjahr auch wenn 90
prozent der malischen bevölkerung die
militärregierung unterstützen können wir
es unseren außenpolitischen zielen nicht
vereinbaren und unseren werten zu sagen
wir bilden weiter malischen soldaten aus
wenn diese menschenrechtsverletzungen
nach ihrer ausbildung gegeben
dennoch ist es wichtig einen
gesprächskanal nicht abreißen zu lassen
sich mit einem schmalen krönte malischen
generalstab bleiben werden wir unseren
schwerpunkt auf niger verlagern und dort
230 soldaten einsetzen um weiter
spezialkräfte auszubilden denn diese
regierungszeit stabilitätsanker in der
region will trotz ihrer schwierigen
rahmenbedingungen dort einen beitrag
leisten für stabilität im saal als
demokratische regierung
womit erreichen wir unsere ziele und
zwar dann unterscheidet sich der einsatz
im niger und die spezialkräfte
ausbildung doch von dem engagement mali
bisher dann haben wir ihn mal imer
ausgebildet aber kein material zur
verfügung gestellt was oft dazu geführt
dass soldaten nach ihrer ausbildung
nicht in ihrer funktion eingesetzt
werden kommt auch nicht dem
ausbildungsverband weiter haben wir das
in liga verändert wir stellen und
infrastruktur wir stellen die ausbildung
und wir stellen die ausrüstung der
tüchtigen die nigrischen
sicherheitskräfte und leisten damit
einen nachhaltigen beitrag zu einer
stabilisierung in der region
[Applaus]
wir sollten immer schauen kein mandat
ist alternativlos das gebietet der
respekt die verantwortung die bei
unseren soldaten die wir in die welt
schicken und gegenüber den familien denn
letztendlich ist es so dass immer das
risiko besteht dass soldaten an leib und
seele verwundet zurückkehren oder sogar
gefallen in einem metall sagt
zurückkehren
deshalb ist es wichtig dieses mandat ihr
hobby ihren das haben wir als appell
koalition vorgenommen und ich hoffe es
unsere nationale sicherheitsstrategie
dazu beitragen wird dass hier noch
einfacher an festen kriterien evaluieren
können lohnt sich engagement lohnt es
sich nicht wie erreichen wir das und das
haben wir getan wir haben ihr personal
ansatz reduziert wir haben den
schwerpunkt verändert wir haben statt
gestrichen aus dem mandatsgebiet und ich
denke alle dass wir dazu beitragen dass
wir jetzt mit diesem ansatz erfolgreich
in niger weiter agieren können und auch
in einem jahr wenn dieses mal dazu über
prüfung ansteht erneut darüber sprechen
können ob wir unsere ziele erreicht
haben oder nicht und dementsprechend
gegebenenfalls noch einmal anpassen
werden
ich halte mal die letzten sekunden an
erlauben sie noch aus der fraktion die
linke eine zwischenbemerkung dazwischen
fragen ein
die soldaten können sich auf uns
verlassen dass wir verantwortungsvoll
entscheiden und treffen ich möchte noch
mal einen soldaten danken die sich in
mali engagieren die unter schwierigsten
bedingungen ihren dienst leisten mali
und im sehr und
möchte für die zustimmung zum mandat
werben vielen dank
ich schließe damit die aussprache zu
diesem tagesordnungspunkt wir kommen zur
abstimmung über die beschlussempfehlung
des auswärtigen ausschusses zu dem
antrag der bundesregierung zur
fortsetzung der beteiligung bewaffneter
deutscher streitkräfte am fähigkeit
aufbau der europäischen union im sahel
mit schwerpunkt nieder abgekürzt tm mali
der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache
1879 dem antrag der bundesregierung auf
drucksache
1762 anzunehmen
wir stimmen nun über die
beschlussempfehlung namentlich ab die
abstimmung erfolgt wieder in der west
lobby sie zur abgabe ihrer stimme haben
sie 20 minuten zeit die
schriftführerinnen und schriftführer
haben ihre plätze bereits eingenommen
ich eröffne damit die namentliche
abstimmung über die beschlussempfehlung
auf drucksache
1879 die abstimmungs orden werden circa
10 uhr 55 geschlossen das bevorstehende
ende der namentlichen abstimmung wird
ihnen noch mal rechtzeitig bekannt
gegeben
ich rufe nun auf den zusatzpunkt 5 sowie
tagesordnungspunkt 30
beratung des antrags der fraktion der
cdu/csu mit dem titel den traum von den
eigenen vier wänden ermöglichen
sowie beratungen der beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für klimaschutz und
energie zu dem entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu zu der abgabe
einer regierungserklärung
durch den bundesminister für wirtschaft
und klimaschutz zu dem thema für eine
sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
transformation innovativ gestalten
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
2022 für die beschlussempfehlung zu dem
entschließungsantrag der fraktionen der
cdu/csu werden wir später namentlich
abstimmen
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten vereinbart ich bitte sie
die platzwechsel jetzt vorzunehmen
und wir nutzen fix die gelegenheit ihn
ein zwei sätze noch zusagen zum jetzt
folgenden tagesordnungspunkte dem unter
anderem ein antrag der unionsfraktion
zugrunde liegt dem traum von den eigenen
vier wänden ermöglichen hatte bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas schon vorgetragen
erster redner hier wird sein jan marco
luczak aus eben der unionsfraktion es
geht unter anderem um vorteile für alle
diejenigen die energieeffizient neu
bauen wollen
das ist gelebte freiheit das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat das mal
sehr schön in die worte gekleidet das
eigentum die wirtschaftliche basis für
individuelle freiheit ist und das ist
auch so und eigentum ein eigenheim das
ist noch viel mehr das ist eine gute
altersvorsorge es sicherheit
unabhängigkeit vor steigenden mieten
unabhängigkeit vor inflation und
deswegen ist es auch nicht verwunderlich
dass millionen von menschen in unserem
land davon träumen vier von fünf träumen
diesen traum von den eigenen vier wänden
die wahrheit aber leider ist das sich
viel zu wenige menschen diesen trauben
auch verwirklichen lassen er bleibt ein
traum deutschland ist in europa
schlusslicht bei der eigentumsquote und
das gilt gerade für junge familien gilt
für menschen mit geringen oder mittleren
einkommen
alle träumen diesen traum aber eher
zerplatzt allzu oft an steigenden kosten
beim bauen am zu wenig bauen anfangen
zur verfügung steht und manchmal eben
auch an den politischen
rahmenbedingungen und
dann müsste es ja eigentlich wenn man
das hört dass millionen menschen davon
träumen eigentlich ausfluss einer guten
einer bürgernahen politik sein
darauf zu reagieren diesen menschen das
zu ermöglichen diesen traum von den
eigenen vier wänden auch wirklich zu
leben wenn man jetzt immer gucken was
macht denn die ampel an der stelle da
muss man leider konstatieren das ist
eine große leerstelle die die ampel an
dieser stelle hat im koalitionsvertrag
im koalitionsvertrag wenn wir demnächst
da gab es noch höhere ziele es gab wohl
klingende versprechen das man
eigenkapital a60 darin machen möchte
zinsverbilligung und viele viele sachen
mehr die ihr den richtigen weg
eingeschlagen hat und ich war
ehrlicherweise auch ganz positiv
überrascht als ich das gelesen habe wenn
man sich jetzt noch mal die realität
anschaut was bleibt eigentlich davon
übrig muss man feststellen nichts nichts
bleibt von diesen hehren zielen und wog
liegen dem versprechen übrig denn was
macht die ampel im haushalt gibt es
keinen eigenen ansatz um das thema
eigentumsbildung die förderung von
jungen familie an dieser stelle nach
vorne zu bringen ganz im gegenteil wir
müssen schon dass das baukindergeld eine
maßnahme die wir als union auf den weg
gebracht haben wo viele hunderttausende
familien von profitiert haben was sie
einer riesengroßen beliebtheit erfreut
dass das wahrscheinlich so sein wird
dass viele familien die antrags
förderberechtigt sind am ende leer
ausgehen weil die gelder nicht
bereitgestellt werden wir haben erlebt
dass wir einen kaffee förderstopp gehabt
haben der massiv vertrauen zerstört hat
der jungen familien auf den weg in die
eigenen vier wände die grundlage ihrer
finanzierung unter dem boden
und wir sehen dass die ministerin die ja
eigentlich die erste wäre die diese
maßnahmen nach vorne bringen müsste die
in zeitungsinterviews sich einlässt und
sagt na ja also der bau von neuen
einfamilienhäusern das ökologisch und
ökonomisch unsinnig meine damen und
herren liebe kolleginnen kollegen von
der abhängig sagen ihnen das sind die
völlig falschen weichen stimmen das sind
die falschen signale wir müssen das
gegenteil machen wir müssen mehr
menschen in die eigenen vier wände
bringen und das versäumen sie mit ihrer
politik
und das greifen sie auch als union in
einem papier wo wir neun punkte
herausgearbeitet haben was die richtigen
weichenstellungen waren um genau dieses
zeit zu dieses ziel traum von den
eigenen vier wänden zu ermöglichen da
geht es darum dass wir eine verlässliche
eine auskömmliche und eine nachhaltige
kfw-förderung auf den weg bringen die
diesen dreiklang ermöglicht neubau
eigentumsbildung klimaschutz und
gleichzeitig dann auch bezahlbare mieten
was werden wir nur hinkriegen wenn
dieses förderkreis dieses hin und her
beim kfw endlich aufhört und die
menschen die bauherren planungs und
investitionssicherheit haben dass sie
auf den weg sich machen können um neu zu
bauen bezahlbar zu blau
energieeffizienten bauen und nicht das
wir jetzt haben diesen atlantis muss
dass alle projekte zurückgestellt werden
weil die keiner weiß wie es denn
eigentlich weitergeht sie müssen endlich
klarheit schaffen wie es weitergeht der
karten und
natürlich müssen wir vor allem bei den
nebenkosten runterkommen und da möchte
ich in stone die grunderwerbsteuer
adressieren das ist eine steuer die in
den letzten jahren vom aufkommt enorm
angestiegen ist wir prognostizieren dass
etwa 20 22 ein volumen von etwa 18
milliarden euro bei der
grunderwerbsteuer geben ist ja klar weil
die kaufkosten sich so die
immobilienpreise sich so entwickeln
steigt diese steuer aber das ist gerade
etwas was eine riesige hürde ist gerade
für junge familien diese nebenkosten
kriegen sie nicht finanziert die
finanziert ihnen keine bank deswegen
brauchen sie dort eigenkapital und wir
wissen alle dass menschen mit geringen
mit mittleren einkommen junge familien
denen fehlt dieses eigenkapital und
deswegen sagen wir als union wir
brauchen für selbst genutztes
wohneigentum
da brauchen wir frei verträge
familienfreundlich ausgestaltet dass die
auch junge menschen familien endlich
diesen traum leben können und deswegen
sage ich das nochmal ihr
bundesfinanzminister jetzt
bundeskanzlers der hat das in der
letzten wahlperiode verschleppt hat sich
nicht mit den ländern aus geld das muss
jetzt endlich anders werden wir brauchen
diese freibeträge bei der grundsteuer
oder
letzten punkt hätte ich noch ganz kurz
abgeben möchte uns geht es vor allen
dingen darum auch viele mieterinnen und
mietern endlich die möglichkeit die
chance zu geben eigentum und herren und
deswegen setzen wir uns so staatlich
abgesicherte mietkauf modelle ein dass
man über eine lange frist statt miete
alleine zu zahlen in die eigene tasche
ins eigene portemonnaie zahlen kannte
wohl leisten kann und am ende als mieter
auch die chance hat eigentümer zu erben
wir brauchen eine gemeinsame
kraftanstrengung ich will hier wollen
als union dass deutschland kein land von
träumen bleibt sondern dass es ein land
von eigentümern wird unterstützen uns
dabei wir sind dazu bereit wir haben die
richtigen konzepte vorgelegt deswegen
unterstützen sie unseren antrag vielen
dank
sagte jan marco luczak der sprecher für
wohnen stadtentwicklung bauwesen und
kommunen in der unionsfraktion und der
wird eine direkte antwort bekommen auf
seine forderungen von klara geywitz der
zuständigen bauministerium
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe cdu fraktion ganz
herzlichen dank für diesen antrag ich
glaube angesichts der vielen
herausforderungen die wir gerade im
bausektor haben ist es ja gut dass wir
uns die zeit nehmen darüber zu sprechen
wie es die menschen in diesem land
schaffen ab preiswerten wohnraum für
sich zu finden wie wir neubau fördern
können die wir die sanierung fördern
können das kann man sehr ruhig und
sachlich miteinander besprechen ich bin
ja auch dafür bekannt dass ich
eigentlich eher eine ruhige person bin
an der stelle möchte ich aber doch mal
eine emotion äußern herr dr es ist für
mich nicht ganz nachvollziehbar dass
mich der hatte ich verkürzt zitieren sie
sagen ich hätte was dagegen die häuser
zu bauen weil das ökonomisch und
ökologisch unsinnig ist das wäre in der
tat etwas verwunderlich wenn die
ministerin grundsätzlich probleme mit
dem bauen hat deswegen bitte ich dass
sie auch das zitat nochmal nachlesen da
stand es ist ökonomisch und ökologisch
unsinnig wenn jede generation ihre
eigenen eigenheim gebaut und
ehrlich gesagt das ist jetzt nicht so
revolutionär dass ich der erste mensch
der auf diese idee gekommen ist sondern
wir haben in deutschland seit
jahrhunderten die tradition das
natürlich häuser von einer familien die
nächst gefeiert werden das ist ganz klar
ist dass man sein elternhaus hat dass
man dort dass man es modernisiert und
das was heute passiert ist doch dass
viele menschen nicht mehr in dem dorf
wurden in dem ihre eltern wohnen und das
heißt dass sie wenn sie ein eigenes haus
haben erst mal daran denken ich brauche
ein neues das alter der eltern ist ja
nicht da wo man gut so und das ist was
wir adressieren müssen wir haben seit
dem krieg tausende von
einfamilienhäusern gebaut in denen keine
familien mehr leben sondern die dann
irgendwann demnächst auch zum
weiterverkauf anstehen wir haben ein
riesiges sanierungsstau in diesem
bereich der gebäudesektor ist ein großes
problem bei der erreichung der
klimaziele und in der tat haben wir sehr
viele familien die nachvollziehbarer
weise davon träumen dass sie ein eigenes
häuschen mit garten haben ich als mutter
von drei kindern kann das sehr gut
nachvollziehen aber wie bringen wir denn
diese beiden gesellschaftlichen sachen
zusammen die vielen häuser die es schon
gibt im bestand die alle eine neue
heizung brauchen die gedämmt werden
müssen die energetisch saniert werden
müssen und die nachvollziehbaren wunsch
da ist eine sache ist ganz einfach
nämlich eine sanierungsförderung dass
wir den anreiz setzen dass die jungen
familien auch darüber nachdenken sich
ein wunderschönes bestands auszuwählen
und für ihre bedürfnisse hin zu bauen
und die waren ja ich war ja bei ihnen
herr dr das war ja bei ihnen in der
fraktion in der arbeitsgruppe vielen
dank auch für die gute diskussion wird
und da haben wir gemeinsam mehr zum
beispiel war das von ihnen erwähnte
programm jung kauft alt gesprochen das
ist etwas was es schon gibt was wir
gerne stärken wollen und es gibt auch in
der wg sanierungsförderung da einen
großen anreiz dass man jetzt schon sagt
ja ich erwerbe und mein ziel ist es mit
den modellen die wir entwickeln werden
für die eigentumsförderung dass eine
feste verabredung sie haben den
koalitionsvertrag erwähnt dass wir da
auf einen schwerpunkt setzen auf die
sanierungsförderung
ein weiterer punkt den wir umsetzen
werden ist die anhebung der linearen
abschreibung von 2 auf 3 prozent und ich
denke es ist ihnen sicherlich auch nicht
entgangen dass der kollege christian
linder gerade sehr intensiv dabei ist
mit den ländern darüber zu sprechen wie
sich die gründer werk steuer so
entwickelt wie sie das auf angedeutet
haben dass die länder in der lage sind
auch differenzierte hebesätze zu machen
es ist ja so die meisten menschen bauen
sich nur ein einziges mal in ihrem leben
ein haus und da kann man dann darüber
auch nachdenken einen anderen
grunderwerbssteuer hebesatz zu nehmen
wichtig ist und das war gestern viele
von ihnen waren ja auch dabei beim tag
der bauindustrie dass wir jetzt
reagieren auf die baukosten steigung und
es ist natürlich nicht denkbar dass wir
sämtliche baumaterialien so
funktionieren aber wir müssen überlegen
wie wir in dieser situation dämpfend auf
die baukosten einwirken können und da
ist ein wichtiger punkt die ganze frage
der modernisierung der bauindustrie in
zehn jahren werden baustellen anders
aussehen mit weniger fachkräften und
mehr technisierung mit mehr
digitalisierung und wir werden natürlich
mit anderen baumaterialien arbeiten ein
wichtiger punkt auch zur kostendämpfung
ist die ganze entwicklung sehr jenes
baum modulares bauen typisierte bauen
und ja das sieht dann auch schön aus ja
das kann man auch mit nachhaltigen
materialien machen und nein das sieht
nicht aus wie den siebziger jahren
ich lade alle dazu ein das wir gerade in
diesem punkt auf die länder zugehen sie
wissen die bauordnung das ist 16 mal
unterschiedlich in deutschland wenn sie
wirklich kosten einsparen mit
typisierten bauern machen dann muss es
natürlich möglich sein denselben bauten
von hamburg bis nach münchen zu bauen da
werden wir mit den kollegen in den
ländern sprechen müssen ich habe es ja
auch eingeladen im bündnis für
bezahlbares bauen und ich würde mich
auch sehr freuen dr luczak wenn ich dann
auch auf sie zugehen könnte auf die
unionsfraktion dass wir in die
wesentlichen bestimmungen der bauordnung
dann auch in deutschland
vereinheitlichen um die bauindustrie von
unnötiger bürokratie zu entlasten
sagt klara geywitz die
bundesbauministerium die auch wiederholt
in ihrem beitrag betont hat wie
positiv sehe dem austausch mit der
unionsfraktion zu sehen wird marc
bernhard ist der nächste redner aus der
fdp fraktion unter ist der bau und
wohnungspolitischer sprecher
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die mieten sind ganz oben und das
vertrauen in die regierung ganz unten
ein halbes jahr ampel regierung hat
genügt um den traum vieler menschen von
den eigenen vier wänden gründlich zu
zerstören im januar haben sie von der
regierung die kfw förderung von heute
auf morgen ohne irgendeine vorwarnung
eine woche vor dem offiziellen ende
einfach gestoppt und damit viele tausend
familien
die eigenen vier wände gestohlen
menschen die bereits viele zehntausend
euro in architektenpläne
energieberater
grundstückskauf baugenehmigungen
grunderwerbsteuer notarkosten und so
weiter bezahlt haben und sich auf ihr
förder versprechen verlassen haben
viele von diesen menschen stehen jetzt
wegen dieser regierung mit vielen
tausend euro schulden da ohne hoffnung
sich die eigenen vier wände noch leisten
zu können und diejenigen die sich noch
leisten konnten für viele weitere 1000
euro die baupläne und die energetische
planung so zu ändern dass sie ihren
neuen förderprogramm nach kfw 40
standard entsprechen haben sie nun
endgültig am boden zerstört indem sie
ihr vor ihren neues förder versprechen
nach gerade mal 3
stunden ohne jegliche vorwarnung
gestoppt haben sie haben also innerhalb
kürzester zeit das vertrauen und damit
den traum von den eigenen vier wänden
für viele menschen ruiniert und
jetzt wollen gerade ausgerechnet sie von
der union die in der vorgängerregierung
dieses ganze desaster mit verursacht hat
angeblich den traum von den eigenen vier
wänden ermöglichen
schönes dass sie dafür den fdp antrag
aus dem jahr 2018 offensichtlich gelesen
und vieles richtige daraus abgeschrieben
haben was sie damals als regierung
abgelehnt haben wollen sie also jetzt
angeblich selber umsetzen
jede scheinheiligkeit geht aber noch
weiter denn natürlich ist es richtig
dass die grunderwerbsteuer wie von uns
seit jahren gefordert gesenkt werden
muss ganz besonders für junge familien
aber es waren doch gerade sie von der
union die die grunderwerbsteuer immer
weiter in die höhe getrieben hat bereits
die unionsgeführte regierung unter
helmut kohl bereits 1997 die
grunderwerbsteuer von 2 auf 3,5 prozent
erhöht und es war die unionsgeführte
regierung unter angela merkel die es
2006 den bundesländern ermöglicht hat
die grundsteuer selbstständig weiter zu
erhöhen und die erhöhung sind natürlich
postwendend auch gekommen und besonders
peinlich muss ich schon mal sagen für
den antrag ist aber dass gerade die cdu
regierten länder nordrhein-westfalen und
schleswig-holstein heute den höchsten
grunderwerbssteuer absatz in deutschland
haben nämlich 6,5 prozent wenn sie also
wenn sie also die menschen wirklich
entlassen entlasten wollen würden dann
hätten sie doch 16 jahre dafür zeit
gehabt 16 jahre nichts gemacht und in
der von ihnen regierten ländern könnten
sie immer noch sofort handeln und die
grunderwerbsteuer auf 3,5 prozent senken
dass sie das nicht tun daran sieht man
dass es sich bei ihrem antrag um nichts
anderes als einen billigen
schaufensterantrag ohne jegliche
substanz handelt
die deutsche bundesbank stellt fest dass
das größte hindernis für die vier
eigenen vier wände die hohen
grunderwerbsteuer in deutschland sind
und deren höhe ist die direkte folge der
unionspolitik der letzten jahre die cdu
ist also das größte hindernis für den
traum von den eigenen vier wänden hier
in deutschland
und das sieht man auch ganz klar und
deutlich bei den wohnungsbau kosten in
16 jahren merkel sind die kosten des
wohnens durch unzählige komplizierte
bauvorschriften und energetische
vorgaben geradezu explodiert teure
heizungsanlagen in bremen extreme
wärmeschutzverglasungen zweifelhafte dem
vorschriften die einen regelrechten dem
bahn ausgelöst haben über 500 milliarden
euro styropor wurden auch deutsche
häuser geklebt ohne dass es laut
deutschen wirtschaftsinstitute
irgendeinen nutzen gehabt hätte wenn die
union jetzt in ihrem antrag die von ihr
selbst eingeführten kostentreibenden
anforderungen angeblich senken will dann
ist es nix als blanker hohn
tatsache ist
dass er neu gebauter quadratmeter in
deutschland an wohnfläche heute im
schnitt 3400 euro kostet und das ganze
zu einer kaltmiete von mindestens 13
euro 50 für und das können sich eben 80
prozent der menschen in unserem land
nicht leisten
deutschland hat also nicht ohne grund
ist nicht ohne grund schlusslicht in
europa aus die wohneigentumsquote
betrifft sondern die deutsche bundesbank
stellt klar fest dass die
wohnungspolitik der regierung dafür
verantwortlich ist dass unsere
wohneigentumsquote die niedrigste in
ganz europa ist nämlich gerade mal 45
prozent während der europäische
durchschnitt deutlich über 70 liegt wir
wollen deutschland von einem land der
mieter zu einem land der eigentümer
machen und darum fordern wir erstens
alle kostentreibenden bauvorschriften
müssen auf ein erträgliches maß
reduziert und kostentreiber eliminiert
werden
zweitens die abschaffung der grundsteuer
das wäre nämlich der sofortige
entlastung für jeden haushalt in unserem
land von 400 bis 500 euro pro jahr
drittens eine generelle absenkung der
grunderwerbsteuer auf 3,5 prozent
und viertens eine komplette grunderwerb
steuerbefreiung für die ersten selbst
genutzten eigenen vier wände
und liebe kollegen liebe kollegen von
der union es macht doch einfach viel
mehr sinn den anträgen der afg gleich
zuzustimmen statt sie erst abzulehnen
und dann hier als plagiat wieder
einzubringen herzlichen dank
ich komme kurz kurz zurück zu
tagesordnungspunkt 27 die zeit für die
namentliche abstimmung ist gleich vorbei
ich möchte daher fragen ist noch ein
mitglied des hauses anwesend das noch
nicht abgestimmt hat
das sieht nicht danach aus dann würde
ich die abstimmung jetzt schließen und
bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer im moment einer einer
rente noch oder 2
dann warten wir das noch kurz ab und
dann rufe ich aber in der zeit
die nächste rednerin auch für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen dr sandra
peter
sehr verehrte präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen wohnen ist so
viel mehr als er dachte warum kopf und
wo und wie wir wohnen entscheidet
darüber ob wir uns als teil dieser
gesellschaft fühlen ob wir wurzeln
schlagen und ja ob wir uns frei fühlen
und
nein der markt regelt leider nicht die
versorgung mit bezahlbaren
klimafreundlichen sozial durch wüssten
wo daumen alleine
das ist die bittere erkenntnis aus den
die regulierungs fehlern der 1990 er
jahre der rückzug des bundes damals aus
der wohnraumförderung oder auch der
verkauf der kommunalen
wohnungsgesellschaften die wir gesehen
haben sie haben dazu geführt dass der
wohnraummangel heute eine der sozialen
fragen unserer zeit ist und darum ist es
genau richtig dass die ampel koalition
die wohnungspolitik ins zentrum ihrer
politik stellen
und ja dabei ist natürlich die bedeutung
der grauen energie im gebäudesektor ganz
enorm und wenn wir uns jetzt gemeinsam
auf den weg gemacht haben richtung
klimaneutralität dann ist es ist auch
ganz entscheidend dass wir in zukunft
klimafreundlich bauen und
klimafreundlich sanieren und genau
dieses problem adressiert doch jetzt die
neue kfw förderung der bundesregierung
für effiziente gebäude es ist so dass
jetzt ab dem 22 neben die neuen anträge
für das kfw punkte haben 40 gestellt
werden konnten nachdem das programm eben
nicht vor der alten regierung aus
finanziert worden ist und das war das
problem dass wir jetzt hatten so umgehen
adressiert worden und deswegen sind wir
jetzt in dem zweiten schritt dieses
programm zyklus jetzt können anträge
gestellt werden die auch die kriterien
für nachhaltiges bauen erfüllen und da
ist ganz wichtige weiterentwicklung
jetzt drin weil ich denke schon dass wir
uns hier in diesem hause unter
demokratinnen und demokraten einig sind
dass wir genau da natürlich rein gehen
wollen mit der staatlichen finanzierung
wo die wertvollen steuer euros auch den
größten effekt haben und genau das ist
jetzt in dem fall vorhanden
ab 20 23 dann werden wir neues
umfassendes programm mit dem titel
klimafreundliches bauen auflegen mit dem
besonders auch die
treibhausgasemissionen über den
kompletten lebenszyklus eines gebäudes
stärker im fokus sind und ich glaube
darf werden wichtige schritte gemacht um
eben auch den bausektor in die
klimaneutralität zu integrieren liebe
union sie sehen die guten ideen in ihren
anträgen die haben wir in der umsetzung
die schlechten werden wir auch weiter
den bürgerinnen und bürgern ersparen und
ich glaube 1 zeichnet diese
förderpolitik aus der ampel wir
verbinden die anreize mit der ambition
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
dong aus der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen zum union zu antrag zum thema
wohnen förderung von wohneigentum
jetzt hat bundestags präsidentin bärbel
war es auch die abstimmung zum eu zur eu
mission beziehungsweise der beteiligung
der bundeswehr daran
beendet geschlossen die stimmen werden
jetzt ausgezählt ihnen gut 15 bis 20
minuten wissen wir auch hier zu mehr es
wird wahrscheinlich nicht viel anders
ausfallen als das ergebnis zur un
mission zu mali nächster redner hier in
dieser debatte ist christi anleihe kommt
aus der linksfraktion und ist
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher dort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren das ist ja heute schon
ein seltsamer an lassen da bemüht die
union im jahreswirtschaftsbericht weil
ein vollkommen überlaufen des bau
förderte gestoppt wurde das noch aus
ihrer eigenen amtszeit stammt ich meine
sie reden über häusle bauen wenn sagen
wir mal eine facharbeiter familie ein
häuschen bord dann wollen wir ja auch
dass die sicherheit dabei haben aber bei
dem programm über das wir heute reden
waren 75 prozent der nicht genehmigten
anträge anträge von unternehmen und eben
nicht von menschen die den traum von den
eigenen vier wänden haben wie es in
ihrem antrag heißt und meine kollegin
karin leicher immobilienwirtschaft genau
auf die finger und da stellt sich für
uns die frage wie viele millionen von
euro sind eigentlich aus diesen
fördertöpfen in wohnungskonzern vivo
novia geflossen weil ich glaube nicht
dass hier jemand dort wohnt spaß macht
das nicht das kann ich ihnen sagen und
dann spielte und schon heute den rächer
der arbeiterklasse und das ist schon ein
dickes ding und sie geben dann der ampel
die schuld verliert das programm
gestoppt und als neuer abgeordneter
denkt man sich da manchmal hätte die
union in den letzten jahren mal im
kanzleramt gesessen dann hätten wir
viele probleme heute nicht union ich
hatte da jetzt eine geheime botschaft an
sie versteckt in diesen worten haben sie
die gefunden sie haben die hier von ok
dann zur ampel weil die drängenden
probleme werden wir auch von nicht
angegangen wir bräuchten 6,3 millionen
sozialwohnungen haben aber gerade mal
noch eine million sozialwohnung das ist
ein historischer tiefstand und dann
werden energie gehäuse mit 18 milliarden
euro gefördert und durch eine anfrage
von meinem kollegen pascal leyser wissen
wir dass sie nicht wissen wie viel davon
eigentlich sozialer wohnungsbau war 18
milliarden euro gibt es für energie
häuser und für den sozialen wohnungsbau
gibt es zwei milliarden aber eine davon
heißt klima milliarden war die grünen
sind mit an bord und ampel da war jetzt
eine versteckte botschaft für sie drin
ja ich sage das weil ich bin ja eher so
der subtile typen
sondern mal klartext wenn wir hier schon
mit dem jahreswirtschaftsbericht
so großes ballett tanzen dann sollte man
sich auch um die großen fragen kümmern
die die menschen da draußen beschäftigen
das ist nun mal eine energiepreis krise
und das ist eine inflation die den
menschen den boden unter den füßen
wegzieht die menschen zahlen bei jedem
wocheneinkauf dick oben brauchen sie
angst vor der nächsten
heizkostenabrechnung und darum muss es
doch wir gehen und nicht um die
interessen der bauwirtschaft sondern um
die interessen der menschen die uns
gewählt haben meine damen und herren
und der punkt es gibt im moment genügend
gas es liegt also nicht am mangelnden
angeboten eines werden ja sogar noch gas
vorräte angelegt und trotzdem steigen
die preise und da will ich ihnen noch
einen subtilen hinweis geben nämlich
geht es dabei um die energie
börse anfang des jahres brach der
wichtige gas terminkontrakt dutch tt es
plötzlich um die hälfte ein und warum
weil es aussichten auf gutes wetter gab
wegen einer verdammten wetterprognose
bricht ein wichtiger gas terminkontrakt
um die hälfte ein ja was glauben sie was
an der börse los ist wenn dann ein krieg
ausbricht und deswegen sagen wir
spekulationen dort müssen verboten
werden das funktioniert nicht in einer
gegen die preiskrise
und deswegen schlagen wir als linke vor
das zu einer staatlichen kontrolle von
energiepreisen kommt dass der staat
kontrolliert was sind eigentlich die
erzeugerkosten was sind die
produktionskosten und das spekulationen
und krisengewinner verboten werden
wissen sie auch warum weil energie zur
daseinsvorsorge gehört in unserer
gesellschaft kann niemand ohne energie
leben oder kennen sie jemanden und weil
die energiepreise die inflation treiben
und zwar doppelt einmal durch öl gas und
strom und einmal bei in allen anderen
produkten energie da drinsteckt und
deswegen sagen wir das recht auf profit
und das recht auf krisen gewinne von
einigen wenigen ist nicht höher als das
recht von allen anderen auf ein leben
ohne angst vor dem ende des monats
dankeschön
für die linksfraktion wo er
wirtschaftspolitischer sprecher ist mit
einem exkurs zum thema energiekosten
daniel fürst für die fdp-fraktion und
sie sehen das präsidium hat gewechselt
der bundestags präsidentin bärbel bas
ist aydan özoguz gefolgt die bundestags
vize
premier ziemlich sicher dass die union
nicht großes ballett tanz mit
wirtschaftsbericht die trumpet
unbeholfen durch den raum und das ist ja
auch der punkt ja
millionen menschen haben den traum vom
eigentum das ist ein gelebtes
aufstiegsversprechen ist eine
lebensleistung wohneigentum schafft
sicherheit schutz vor altersarmut nicht
nur die generation dieser reichtum auch
generationen darüber hinaus und
vielleicht noch eine wichtige
informationen an den eher links
orientierten teil dieses plenums
wohneigentum schließt die
vermögensverteilung es ist sozial
gerecht und deswegen ist es für uns
freidemokraten völlig außer frage wir
wollen deutschland zu einer eigentümer
nation machen
auch auf dem weg dahin muss
man ja feststellen ist noch viel zu tun
der luchs sie wissen die eigentumsquote
in deutschland stagniert und trotz das
von ihnen gefeierten kindergeld sie
zuletzt gesunken
gleichzeitig steigen die preise
gleichzeitig sinkt das angebot also es
gibt guten grund dass sie hier das
thematisieren das thema wohneigentum
weil wir natürlich großen wunsch haben
aber einige probleme und da finde ich es
wirklich beeindruckend dass sie das tun
obwohl sie wissen dass wir dann auch
darüber reden was in den letzten 16
jahren alles nicht gemacht haben und das
ist fast ein selbstloser zug weil wer
hat sie denn eigentlich aufgehalten die
kv eigentumsförderung auszubauen wir
kriegen das mit der spd hin wer hat sie
denn aufgehalten die wunderbare
freibeträge zu machen wir kriegen das
mit unserem koalitionspartner
da muss man ehrlich sagen wenn über
wohneigentum reden und es ist wichtig
dass wir das thematisiert da müsse man
aber auch einmal sagen warum deutschland
da steht wo sie steht oder man echt
sagen da hilft dir antrag bei der
vergangenheitsbewältigung schon beim
blick in die zukunft nicht
zwei punkte zwei punkte muss ich aber
gesondert aus nehmen weil die haben mich
hier bis lackiert
sie aber ihre eigene interpretation des
grunderwerbs mehr freibetrags
für jeden erwachsenen
250.000 euro für jedes kind 150000 euro
eine millionen euro grunderwerbsteuer
freibetrag für eine vierköpfige familie
glauben sie ernsthaft dass einer ihrer
ministerpräsidenten der herr wüst oder
der hersteller auch nur annähernd eine
million euro 100 euro freibetrag
ausreichend wird das ist eine
schaufenster witz ohnegleichen
dass ich so was nicht wirklich und was
nicht was mich was ich unanständig sind
was ich echt und nicht finden ich weiß
nicht wie sie darauf pochen aber dass
sie dass sie in sie nun ihren wir würden
[Musik]
das ebenso ihren bewährten gegebene
förder versprechen nicht halten also das
baukindergeld geben denen es bewilligt
wurde sei unsicher ich finde das nicht
nur erbärmlich ich finde es unsäglich
der deutsche staat hält sich natürlich
an die verträge dir abgeschlossen hat
das einzige was überraschend kam war das
komplette kfw aus dass sie ausgelöst
haben und da nicht zugegen
war der kaffee forderung haben wir
tatsächlich haben wir tatsächlich in den
ersten monaten nicht optimal regiert
ja es ist ja im gegensatz zu union hilft
ja selbsterkenntnis beim besser werden
sie haben sich 16 jahre alles angeschaut
haben nichts gemacht und sind jetzt hier
für grusel reden ja die erst das erste
quartal bei der kfw förderung war nicht
optimal aber jetzt läuft das programm
und die vorarbeiten für ein neues
programm das sich auch die menge der
gesparten auf die gesparte menge co2
konzentriert das technologieoffen ist
dass die menschen mitnimmt dass es in
arbeit das wird kommen und dann lösen
wir auf dem zielkonflikt co2 reduktion
im bestand und bezahlbarer wohnraum
dafür werden wir komplett neue förder
systematik aufbaut und so bringen wir
das land voran
ich muss natürlich noch mal zurückkommen
zum eigentum
es ist wirklich wichtig und danke dass
sie es formulieren frau ministerin es
ist wirklich wichtig dass wir an den
baukosten rangehen was wir in den
letzten monaten sehr nicht mal was wir
die letzten monaten gesehen haben an
baukosten bau preissteigerungen ist ist
absurd deswegen ist es dringend und das
erwarte ich auch vom bauministerium vom
bmw sb weil die allein existenz einen
unterschied machen muss deswegen ist es
dringend dass wir an die baukosten
rangehen wir brauchen den baukosten tüv
wir müssen digitalisieren von der
planung über die genehmigung bis zur
ausführung wir müssen entrümpeln alles
das was bremst time is money
geschwindigkeit hilft und da ist viel zu
tun und das werden die freien demokraten
vorantreiben in dieser regierung aber
was wir jetzt alle erst einmal wo wir
zielgenau ansetzen werden letzter satz
frau präsidentin wo wir zielgenau
einsetzen werden ist bei der großen
hürde des eigenkapital auf dem weg ins
eigentum viele viele familien kommen mit
den zinszahlungen einigermaßen zurecht
kräftigen tilgungszahlungen aber das
eigenkapital ist ein problem deswegen
arbeiten wir an eigenkapital ersetzen
darlehen über zwei klagen szene und wir
arbeiten an der grunderwerbsteuer
freibetrag und wenn sie es ernst meinen
mit ihrer wohneigentumsförderung dann
fangen sie jetzt schon an ihre länder zu
überzeugen dass man der kunde werkzeuge
mitgehen dann ohne geländer wird darauf
im eigenheim nichts
zwar jetzt relativ viele letzte setzte
aber hielt sich noch im rahmen
viele kommata
ich komme noch einmal zurück zum
tagesordnungspunkt
27 und verließ ihn das protokoll dass
von den schriftführerin und
schriftführer ermittelten ergebnisses
der namentlichen abstimmung über die
beschlussempfehlung des auswärtigen
ausschusses zu dem antrag der
bundesregierung fortsetzung der
beteiligung bewaffneter deutscher
streitkräfte am fähigkeit aufbau der
europäischen union im sahel mit
schwerpunkt die stereo tim mali
abgegeben anschuldigung drucksachen 20
17 62 und 20 18 79 abgegebene stimmen
karten
657 mit ja haben gestimmt
551 mit nein haben gestimmt
105 enthaltung eine die
beschlussempfehlung ist damit angenommen
wir fahren fort in unserer debatte und
als nächster redner bekommt michael
kiessling von der cdu csu das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten kolleginnen kollegen daher
fürchtet dass eine märchenstunde war da
schon wenn sie sagen sie gegen das kfw
förderprogramm auf die reiter gesehen
also in der vergangenheit habe nichts
gesehen die förderprojekte sie machen
hat nichts mit fördern zu tun das hat
eher etwas mit verhindern also schauen
sie mal dass es hinkriegen und für den
haushalt 22 war natürlich auch sie
beteiligt und letztendlich unser b maria
finanzminister olaf scholz muss man auch
dazusagen und das hat auch die sorge
dafür tragen müssen dass diese lücke
auch weitergeht also wenn wir die ampel
anschaut und die sehr kurz währen der
problembeschreibung aber wenig in der
lösungskompetenz klappt da muss man
hinkommen
und meine damen meine herren die ampel
ist für den wohnungsbau zuständige und
der wohnungsbau steht momentan auf
dunkelrot da geht nichts voran wir haben
baustopp mit dieser förderpolitik die
zahlen gehen zurück es wird nicht so
gebaut und gebaut werden sollte im
bereich zum klimaschutz weil die
förderung ausbleibt und daran müssen wir
noch arbeiten bis in eine situation wo
wir steigende baukosten steigende
zinssätze haben steigende inflation
haben steigende energiekosten haben was
passieren wird nichts keine antwort im
bereich des wohnungsbaus und deshalb
haben wir diesen antrag gestellt wir
sind einmal um den eigentum natürlich zu
fördern es geht auch darauf die
baukosten entsprechend reinzugehen und
es geht auch darum das ganze klima
schonend zu tun was wir momentan sehen
die förderpolitik oder besser sagte
nicht der politik grünen dass
bezahlbarer wohnraum klimaschutz der
traum vom eigenen heim und vor allem das
vertrauen in die politik verloren geht
und die selbst genannte fortschritts
koalition macht genau das gegenteil sie
sorgt nicht für den wohnungsmarkt dass
der dynamik reinkommt im gegenteil er
wird momentan ausgebremst
wer solche entscheidung trifft meine
damen und herren in der wohnungspolitik
der tritt auch das quadrat bei tetris
anders gesagt solche entscheidungen
kommt der bau in keinster weise voran
ja ich hab den subtilen hinweis noch
machen sollen vom kollegen sei aber
gut sei mal dahin gestellt wir brauchen
verlässlichkeit wir brauchen dynamik
fort wir brauchen die förderung für
wohneigentum und letztendlich müssen wir
auch auf die baukostenexplosion
eine antwort finden sie haben gesagt wir
gehen in die zukunft des bauens der bau
muss fortschrittlicher werden alles gut
und richtig wir müssen digitalisieren
auch richtig haben wir auch auf den weg
gebrachten letzten
legislaturperiode aber das hilft uns
doch momentan nicht mit den preisen wir
brauchen doch jetzt auch kurzfristig
eine antwort und da fehlt die antwort
kann man sich vielleicht mal überlegen
kann man steuerlich was tun kann man
über zuschüsse arbeiten wie schaffen wir
die bauwillige entsprechend zu entlassen
das jetzt gebaut wird und dass
bauprojekte nicht verschoben werden wir
brauchen die bau kapazitäten in der
baubranche und der selbst nichts wenn
projekte auf die nächste jahr verschoben
wird meine damen und herren da schafften
wir nicht mehr wohnraum
und was wir auch brauchen wir brauchen
investitionsbedingungen die
funktionieren sonderabschreibungen für
energieeffiziente wohngebäude
wir brauchen die anreize das war
interessant
die kollegen von den grünen dass sie
fördern und wie war der begriff förder
und was hatten sie gesagt an
dem fördern und unterstützen aber das
unterstützen glaube ich ist dann bei
ihnen ja ich hab mir aufgeschrieben ganz
vergessen gibt offen zu aber tempo punkt
war dass sie sagen sie fördern
ambitioniert genauso fördern
ambitioniert aber die ambitionen bei
ihnen ist er vermutlich das
ordnungsrecht wie schaffe ich die leute
dann dazu entsprechend sei man diese
forderung die sie auf den weg bringen
auch umzusetzen und ich glaube wir
müssen anreize schaffen die leute müssen
mitgenommen werden zu bauen und werden
wir sehen welche sanierungsquote dass
wir haben das schreiben ist ein antrag
wir brauchen beides wir brauchen den
neubau wir brauchen wir brauchen die
neubau wir brauchen auch das bauen im
bestand die vorstands nutzung und da ist
doch der punkt wenn die leute gezwungen
werden was zu tun wenn die preise
steigen und wir keine förderung haben
dann hilft auch das ordnungsrecht nicht
weil dadurch wird nicht mehr wohnraum
geschaffen meine damen und herren
schauen sich den antrag noch mal an
nehmen sie die punkte raus wenn sie
nicht unterstützen können ich glaube
sind viele gute punkte dabei um wohnraum
zu schaffen eigentum zu schaffen und
auch bezahlbares wohnen mietern im
eigentum entsprechend zu ermöglichen
herzlichen danke
michael kiessling für die unionsfraktion
in der debatte zum antrag der
unionsfraktionen es geht um die
förderung von wohnungseigentum und es
geht auch das ganze im hinblick auf eine
effiziente
gebäudeausstattung was das heizen angeht
wir sind dran gekommen bei einer daldrup
aus der spd-fraktion und da ist er
kommunalpolitischer sprecher unter
anderem nämlich auch sprecher für wohnen
stadtentwicklung und bauen
cdu/csu das tier des öfteren wir sollten
uns nicht
davon distanzieren dass wir auch 16
jahren gemeinsam regiert haben ich will
das auch gar nicht tun und deswegen
wenn ich das mal ein beispiel deswegen
will ich dass man am beispiel ihres
antrags ein paar stellen deutlich machen
vielleicht noch mit der ministerin an
uli lange art vorgestern getwittert wo
ist die ministerin also heute ist sie
auf der regierungsbank
gestern war sie am tag der bauwirtschaft
vorgestern habe ich sie bei der
bauingenieur kamera getroffen und so
könnte ich weitermachen bei den
mieterverbänden bei der
wohnungswirtschaft diese ministerin
sucht den dialog gibt eigene akzente
motiviert und das ist einer der
unterschiede zu ihrem vorgänger der war
glaube ich so eine art phantom der
politik jedenfalls gesehen was nicht
weiter unterschied
ihr antrag sich den titel den traum von
den eigenen vier wänden verwirklichen
gehen doch eigentumsförderung das ist in
ordnung luczak moment noch die höchste
quote die schweiz glaube ich die
geringste
wenn man das diskutiert wissen sie genau
quote allein macht's nicht sondern es
geht darum dass man sozusagen nicht nur
für diejenigen die eigentum schaffen
wollen das wollen sie das wollen wir
auch aber wir wollen uns um alle kümmern
die bezahlbaren wohnraum kriegen das ist
der feine unterschied zu der
vergangenheit für sie sind mieterinnen
und mieter die nutznießer als folgende
eigentumsbildung sozusagen als sicher
effekt aber das wird der herausforderung
heute nicht gerecht das sage ich
deutlich dritter punkt dritter punkt
baukindergeld wir haben das mitgetragen
ich habe es manchmal mehr vorzeitig also
leute von ihnen fragen sie mal weg
fragen sie mal wir wollten auch etwas
für die eigentumsbildung in den städten
tun kauf von genossenschaftsanteilen
damit man sich in der stadt das grund
auch leisten kann gescheitert mich an
der spd nicht an
am haus seehofer ist es gescheitert und
jetzt im haushalt wird es drin sein 6
millionen damit geht's los am kauf von
genossenschaftsanteilen
förderung eigentumsbildung stimmen sie
zu
vierter punkt kfw-förderung ja das ist
ein kompliziertes thema daniel bösch hat
dazu einiges kritisch ist auch
selbstkritisches gesagt aber ich will
mal vielleicht eins sagen die
ankündigung die löste eine antragsflut
aus dass in der tat war das war die
ankündigung von peter altmaier aber
davon mal abgesehen will ich ihnen das
noch einmal vergegenwärtigen dass man
hätte tun müssen 2009/10
86.000 geförderte wohneinheiten
2020 100
97.000 geförderten wohneinheiten
362.000 geförderte wohneinheiten und das
bei einem programm das mit fünf
milliarden beginnt und mit 16 milliarden
aufhört dann könnte man als
verantwortlicher mal auf die idee kommt
man muss aber steuern wer aber
verantwortlich genau horst war
verantwortlich und peter rahm
verantwortlich und die beiden was haben
sie gemacht gegen den ruf gegen den
gegen die warnungen vom bmwf mix haben
so gemacht und das meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen das ist nicht
sinn eines solchen programmes eines
makan führungsriege standards gestaltet
werden muss wird ihren beherzten spielen
bin ich voll überzeugt
der sinn der förderung war nämlich in
erster linie ein klimapolitischer und
ein technologischer und nicht einfach
die ungesteuerte eigentumsförderung bis
zum penthouse das war nicht sinn der
sache und die anschlussförderung die
jetzt ja das haben sie beklagte in drei
stunden weg war ist doch ganz zeichen
von authentisch muss die ist doch ein
zeichen dafür dass akzeptanz und
wirksamkeit dass die bereitschaft
klimapolitische neubauförderung zu
machen ankommt und das müssen wir
fortsetzen und das haben wir der neue
förderungen dargestellt und das fehlt
bei ihnen ich glaube dass das so sagen
will ich komme zurück zur einführung
grunderwerbsteuer höhe könnte man ja in
den ländern einfach senken in ihren
ländern passiert das genauso wenig wie
andere könnte man machen aber ich will
das noch mal sagen dann hat das
aufgegriffen das worüber sie reden macht
8 milliarden jedes jahr weniger
einnahmen für die länder aus und da bin
ich mal gespannt ob sich das platz seit
ihrer ministerpräsidenten kriegen
übrigens diese grunderwerbsteuer
einnahmen nutzen die länder zur
unterstützung und förderung von
eigentums maßnahmen in den ländern
wollen sie vielleicht nicht mehr kann ja
sein also wir haben das jetzt in den
fokus genommen und sie haben es mit
einer gegenfinanzierung verbunden share
deals also wir wollen sozusagen das
nicht nur die kleinen entlastet werden
sondern die großen auch belastet werden
und sie wollen auch die kleinen
entlasten aversionen allgemeinheit
belasten und die großen laufen lassen
dafür bin ich wie ein unterschied
viele ihrer forderungen die in dem
papier stellen sind in unserem
koalitionsvertrag enthalten ich mache
nicht die nummer auf 16 jahre aber ich
bitte um entschuldigung dass 150 tagen
noch nicht alles abgearbeitet umgesetzt
ist das gebe ich freimütig zu das ist so
alles auf dem anderen aber wir machen
das schon wir werden uns auch mal mit
den index mieten beschäftigen damit man
das kleine eigentum das die menschen
haben dass das verfügbare einkommen
nicht noch mehr weggefressen wird habe
ich keinen vorschlag von ihnen zugesehen
es ist nicht die zeit auf alle
steuerlichen maßnahmen ein zu gehen
würde ich gerne tun aber das klappt
nicht mehr
aber ich will zwei sachen sagen die sie
vergessen haben erstens
sie haben zu der größten blockade der
eigentumsbildung nichts gesagt das sind
die explodierenden bodenpreise nichts um
dazu kunden zweitens
zweitens wir verdreifachen wir
verdreifachen die soziale
wohnraumförderung diese soziale
wohnraumförderung trägt zu einem drittel
zu eigentums maßnahmen in den ländern
30.000 ins gewesen selbst 1001 maßnahmen
das möchten sie offensichtlich in der
form auch nicht und deswegen sage ich
mal sie sind im grunde genommen in der
opposition noch nicht auf dem
erneuerungsprozess angekommen die
erneuerung machen deshalb wir herzlichen
dank
werner daldrup spd-fraktion wohnungs und
baupolitischer sprecher und
kommunalpolitischer sprecher ist ja auch
deswegen weiß auch was vor ort die
kostentreiber sind wenn es um das bauen
geht nächster redner casillas allee aus
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
[Musik]
dass ich auch hier sind endlich nach den
zwei harten jahren
um es gleich vorneweg zu sagen
horst seehofer und peter altmaier haben
den fokus auf die förderprogramme
komplett falsch eingesetzt der fokus lag
auf klimaschädlichen neubau statt auf
der sanierung aber jetzt meine damen und
herren ist es wichtig diesen
gravierenden fehler zu beseitigen und
den fokus endlich auf der sanierer zu
legen um unsere klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen genau das gehen wir es auch an
die meisten gebäude die 20 45 und sohn
klimaneutralen gebäude richtern formen
werden stehen schon heute in einer gut
durchdachten gebäude förderung müssen
sich diese bereits gebauten gebäude also
unbedingt widerspiegeln dafür legen wir
das ökologische fundament um diese
förderung angemessen passend und
zeitgemäß zu gestalten
wir entwickeln die neubauförderung und
die eigentumsförderung bis zum
jahresende weiter und dabei lassen wir
unsere ideen eine ökologischen bau wände
mit einfließen
das bedeutet lebenszyklus betrachtung
eine faire gebäude förderung und die
kreislaufwirtschaft all das
all das meine damen und herren werden in
das neue programm klimafreundliches
bauen mit einfließen und ich wiederhole
es gerne noch mal meine damen und herren
das ist auch bitter nötig im jahr 20 21
hatte gebäudesektor 115 millionen tonnen
co2 äquivalente emittiert
das sind genau 115 millionen co2 tonnen
zu viel und hauptursache
hauptursache dafür dass wir diese
klimaziele im gebäudesektor wie damals
verfehlt haben sind die zahlreichen und
sanierten gebäude in unserem land und
hauptursache dafür dass die nische
längst saniert sind ist peter altmaier
und horst seehofer
die folgen dessen die folgen dessen sind
gleichermaßen fatal für unser klima und
für den menschen mit niedrigen einkommen
die jetzt massiv und steigenden
energiepreisen besonders hart betroffen
sind das problem dass vorliegenden
entschließungsantrag der cdu csu
fraktion ist erstens dass er vieles
fordert was wir bereits angepackt haben
und genau deshalb ist es auch ein
schaufensterantrag
zweiter und wichtigen ist das teilweise
will die union mit diesem antrag in eine
ferne vergangenheit zurück die uns alle
heute aufgezeigten probleme auch
eingebrockt hat und daher meine damen
und herren gehen wir diesen antrag
entschieden auch zurück vielen dank
caserta hergé für die fraktion würden
ist 90 die grünen
es wird weiter diskutiert über einen
antrag der unionsfraktionen es geht um
die förderung von wohneigentum es geht
um die
effiziente heizung ausstattung
beispielsweise in zeiten steigender
energiepreise und zum thema jetzt konrad
stockmeier aus der fdp fraktion dass
sich das schiff diesmal wieder anhört
als ob es die spatzen von den dächern
trällern denn liebe kollegen von der
union das ist wieder ein antrag der nur
darauf hinweist was sie in ihrer vergeht
regierungsverantwortung nicht auf die
reihe gekriegt haben denn nämlich
wirklich eine langfristig orientierte
wohnungsbauförderung aufs gleis zu
setzen die effizienten klimaschutz
wirklich in ganz kurzer blick zurück
auch daran sei noch mal erinnert alle
anträge die zu diesen die bis zu diesem
stopp im januar bei der kfw eingegangen
sind werden ja noch bearbeitet dafür
sind sage und schreibe noch mal fünf
milliarden euro mobilisiert worden und
lassen sie uns aber nun anders als es in
ihrem antrag geschieht wirklich mal den
blick nach vorne richten und dabei wird
klar dass die voerder systematik
wirklich weiterentwickelt werden muss
sowohl aus technologischen und das
möchte ich betonen aber auch aus
fiskalischen gründen
denn nicht nur diesen sondern auch viele
andere anträge aus ihren reihen
durchziehen mittlerweile parteipolitisch
gesprochen fehlten die sowas von tief
rot schimmern dass man sich nur noch
wundern kann denn sie schmeißen auch
wieder in diesem antrag mit geld um sich
als ob es kein morgen gäbe aber es gibt
in diesem land ein morgen in dem die
menschen
energieeffizient klimaschonend und
bezahlbare wohnen können sollen und
deshalb bringen wir wie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart eine
grundlegende neuausrichtung der voerder
systematik auf den weg die sich und das
ist für uns liberale besonders wichtig
auch technologieoffen an der jeweiligen
einspar menge von co2 orientieren wird
eine wirklich wirklich gut gestaltete
und auch in der laufzeit definierte
förderung schafft markt anreize und
stärkt die wirtschaftlichkeit der
implementierten lösungen und zur
wahrheit gehört aber auch dazu das ist
auch hier ein thema ist bei dem
verschiedene politikbereiche ineinander
greifen müssen um das problem zu lösen
also beispielsweise qualifizierung und
auch qualifizierte einwanderung um den
fachkräftemangel zu überwinden die
ampelkoalition ist dran forschung
beispielsweise auch die stärkung der
hochschulen für angewandte
wissenschaften die gerade im baubereich
sehr innovativ unterwegs sind die ampel
ist dran und beispielsweise auch die
vereinfachung von vorschriften und da
kann ich als baden württemberger aus dem
wahlkreis mannheim nur auf die
landesbauordnungen verweisen wenn sie
sich mal an ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen in stuttgart da gibt es viel zu
tun und was ist von alldem in ihrem
antrag zu finden nichts
und der rückwärtsgewandtheit ihres
antrages halte ich entgegen was die
deutsche gesellschaft für nachhaltiges
bauen jüngst in einer aktuellen
stellungnahme der ampelkoalition mit auf
den weg gegeben hat ich zitiere mit
erlaubnis der frau präsidentin
der bundesregierung können wir nur zu
halten sie kurs halten sie den druck aus
und gehen sie diesen weg weiter wir
brauchen die umstellung auf die
zielgröße co2 und die lebenszyklus
betrachtung um zielgerichtet planen
bauen sanieren und gebäude betreiben zu
können dem schließe ich mich an vielen
dank
für die cdu csu fraktion erhält jetzt
das wort an den könig
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sowohl weniger
als auch die baubranche stehen derzeit
vor drei großen herausforderungen zum
einen sind es die extrem lieferengpässe
von baumaterial zum anderen die
explodierenden energiepreise die auch
das bauen massiv verteuern und drittens
ein fachkräftemangel der sich durch alle
segmente der branche zieht und als ob
das nicht noch
und als ob das nicht auch schlimm genug
wäre hat dann die ampel noch einen drauf
gesattelt mit dem drama und die kfw
förderstopp sie haben in der tat ein
trauerspiel in drei akten zustande
gebracht der erste akt beginnt am 24
januar in einer hauruck aktion des
wirtschaftsministeriums wurde der
sofortige kfw förderstopp für
energieeffiziente gebäude war über die
homepage verkündet was nicht nur ein
kommunikations desaster war sondern
zugleich ein schwerer vertrauensbruch
gegenüber baufälligen und vor allem
gegenüber jungen familien die glaubten
dass ihre finanzierung auf sicheren
füßen stehe
und ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich so geht
mit der lebensplanung junger menschen in
diesem land um der wirtschaftsminister
versuchte sich daraufhin in
schadensbegrenzung
er kündigte die fortsetzung der
förderung zumindest für den standard 40
beim neubau an es wurde also
umdisponiert neue energie berater wurden
beauftragt neue finanzierungen wurden
abgeschlossen natürlich jetzt zu
schlechteren bedingungen
aber es folgte der zweite akt des dramas
nach drei monaten langen wartens wurde
innerhalb von drei stunden die
neubauförderung für e h 40 erneut
gestoppt da die eine milliarde euro die
dazu zur verfügung gestellt wurde schon
ausgeschöpft war reichen sollte das geld
ja eigentlich nicht nur für drei stunden
sondern bis zum jahresende
diese kleine fehleinschätzung oder
katastrophale fehleinschätzung die ich
finde des ministeriums war für viele
betroffene ein echter schlag in die
magengrube und ließ den traum vom
eigenen heim endgültig zu platzen
und damit sind wir auch schon beim
dritten akt jetzt gibt es nur noch eine
neubauförderung in kombination mit einem
qualitätssiegel für nachhaltiges bauen
wiederum unter verschlechterten
förderbedingungen
diese dürfen nur von
zertifizierungsstellen ausgestellt
werden von denen es genau drei in
deutschland gibt zudem ist dieses
verfahren extrem langwierig und
kostspielig damit motivieren sie gerade
nicht zum klimafreundlichen bauen
sondern sie schrecken eher davon ab
die von der regierung merkel
eingeführten förderprogramme haben dafür
gesorgt dass sich mehr menschen für
effiziente gebäudesanierung entschieden
haben wir haben damit einen ganz
entscheidenden beitrag für den
klimaschutz geleistet ihr förder chaos
führt dazu dass sich weniger menschen in
zukunft energieeffizienz leisten können
sie betreiben damit eine politik gegen
effizienz und gegen klimaschutz
zudem sendet die ampel ein fatales
signal für die wohnungs und baubranche
ihre politik führt zu auftragseinbrüchen
für mittelständler und handwerker wenn
fest eingeplante zuschüsse wegfallen
werden nicht nur privatleute sondern
auch wohnungsbaugesellschaften ihre
pläne verwerfen und sie halten ganz
trotzig an ihrem ziel jährlich 400.000
neue wohnungen zu bauen aufrecht aber
tun zugleich eigentlich gar nichts dafür
dass das überhaupt noch funktionieren
kann das an sich ja auch recht richtige
ziel der klimaneutralität im
gebäudebestand bis 2050 rückt doch so
auch immer in weiter entfernte
gegenden es reicht eben auch nicht aus
auf feierliche erklärung auch
internationalen klimakonferenzen
abzuheben oder wohlklingende bündnisse
für bezahlbares bauen auszurufen
klimaschutz gelingt in erster linie im
baubereich nur mit unseren handwerkern
bauunternehmern und bauherren vor ort
dies ganz konkret die politik muss die
energiewende auch nicht alleine
schultern aber sie muss den machern vor
ort zumindest verlässlichkeit und
planungssicherheit geben beides leider
fremdworte für die ampeln
es ist es so die von ihnen verursachte
stagnation in der bauwirtschaft zieht in
unserer volkswirtschaft zwangsläufig
noch weitere branchen in mitleidenschaft
wir fordern sie daher in unserem antrag
auf reißen sie das ruder jetzt endlich
herum und sorgen sie wieder für die
richtigen rahmenbedingungen beim bauen
und sanieren in deutschland wenn eine
steigende inflation investieren teurer
macht dann benötigen die bauwilligen
jungen familien aber auch die bauern
wohnungs branche die unterstützung des
staates jetzt in besonderem maße mit
unseren anträgen liefern wir vorschläge
die das von der ampel verursachte
desaster abmildern können wir bieten
ihnen damit einen ausweg aus ihrer
tragödie sie müssen lediglich dafür
unseren anträgen zustimmen vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
an der könig aus der unionsfraktion und
wir nähern uns schon langsam aber sicher
lehre ist sogar ganz so weit ist es noch
gar nicht mehr
beweglich ist die nächste rednerin und
danach folgen erst mal noch drei also
melanie welling aus der spd-fraktion und
wie spricht jetzt
die union verspricht den traum der
eigenen vier wände der titel des
antrages mag ja eigentlich ganz gut
scheinen aber leider eben nur auf den
ersten blick gehen wir mal in die
details sie schreiben dass sie den
erwerb von immobilien für familien mit
geringen und mittleren einkommen fördern
wollen das klingt ja zunächst auch mal
ganz gut aber war ehrlich wo können sich
geringverdiener überhaupt noch
wohneigentum leisten ihnen ist schon
klar dass für viele familien ohne den
ausblick auf eine erbschaft ihr
sogenannter traum ein echter kampf wenn
ich sogar völlig utopisch ist
wie hoch müsste die förderung des
staates sein um diese familien zu
erreichen
das ist augenwischerei
so eine förderung kommt nur
spitzenverdienern zugute und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch der ganze sinn und
zweck dieses antrages
schauen wir uns das mal genauer
eine erzieherin im anerkennungsjahr
verdient monatlich so zirka 1500 euro
brutto damit gehört es in meinem
bundesland hessen gerade so noch zu den
menschen die eine geförderte mietwohnung
beantragen können und die union will
jetzt aber ein eigenheim anpreisen das
ist doch zynisch und vollkommen an
qualität verein
aber bekäme sie dann ja in hessen
überhaupt eine geförderte wohnung
wahrscheinlich nicht denn in hessen sind
die sozial mietwohnung über die letzten
zehn jahre um 35 prozent zurückgegangen
das ist doch die eigentliche baustelle
wird und wer starter gleich bei den
ministerpräsidenten die antragstellenden
fraktionen
es ist immer leicht mehr mittel vom bund
zu fordern aber es muss dann halt auch
in den ländern geliefert werden menschen
mit geringen einkommen brauchen
bezahlbaren wohnraum und keine
luftschlösser in form von unions
anträgen
aber zurück zu genau diesem antrag sie
wollen mehr bauland aufbrach und
konversionsflächen gewinnen ist ihnen
bewusst dass es in ballungsräumen also
dort wo auch die arbeitsplätze für die
angesprochenen menschen mit geringen und
mittleren einkommen sind so gut wie gar
keine bach welchen gibt kommunale
diskussionen beschäftigen sich
mittlerweile längst mit der frage
inwieweit man flächen versiegeln kann
bzw darf hier mal die abwägung zwischen
der nachfrage nach wohnraum einer unter
lebensqualität andererseits nur als
stichworte
angeblich also vorhandene flächen mit
staatlich geförderten einfamilienhäusern
zuzupflastern die dann auch noch für die
vorgegebenen kleinen und mittleren
einkommen völlig unerreichbar sind ist
nicht nur realitätsfern sondern auch
unaufrichtig
ihren antrag aus diesen gründen
abzulehnen ist ganz einfach aber ich
möchte auch darauf eingehen was wir
stattdessen tun werden die ampel
regierung setzt sich dafür ein dass es
wieder mehr sozialwohnungen gibt wir
wollen den ab auch das sozial
wohnungsbestandes bremsen und umkehren
deshalb werden wir den sozialen
wohnungsbau der länder bis 20 26 mit
einer rekord summe von 14,5 milliarden
euro fördern
darin sind auch die mitte für das bund
länder programm für studentisches und
für auszubildende nun ab dem programm
jahr 2023 enthalten schon dieses jahr
packt die ampel zwei milliarden euro in
den sozialen wohnungsbau davon eine
milliarde euro in den klimagerechten
sozialen wohnungsbaus das klingt für
mich doch schon viel eher nach sinnvoll
investierte geld in diesem sinne packen
wir es an vielen dank
als nächste rednerin folgt für bündnis
90/die grünen christina johannes
schröder
[Applaus]
liebe union sie haben wir jetzt ein paar
verbale vorschlag herausgeholt und die
möchte ich jetzt doch zum ende der
debatte noch mal einordnen also erst mal
haben sie die ministerin extrem falsch
zitiert uns war so falsch dass es
einfach unwahr ist die ministerin hat
völlig richtig gesagt dass nicht jede
generation so viel fläche verbrauchen
kann dass sie ihre eigenen eigenheim
bauen kann sondern dass die alten
saniert werden müssen wir haben ja jetzt
endlich wieder
wir haben jetzt ja endlich wieder gäste
nimmt mir und debattieren nicht nur mit
uns und die jungen leute die hier sitzen
von den schulen haben auch ein anrecht
darauf zu überlegen was sie mit ihrer
fläche machen es geht aber nicht wenn
wir deutschland zu gebaut haben
[Applaus]
dann frau könig eine wenn eine milliarde
und drei stunden weg ist dann war das
unglaublich relativ erfolgreich das
förderprogramm das zeigt wie wahnsinnig
gut unsere bauwirtschaft eben effizient
wohnung schaffen kann ich glaube dass es
ganz
dass wir eben die milliarden nutzen um
eine neue förderung auf die beine zu
stellen und noch glauben sie an die
zwischenfrage aus der cdu-fraktion
verlieren
vielen dank frau kollegin dass die
zwischenfrage zu lassen sie haben wir
jetzt gerade auf die bauwirtschaft
reguliert und dass sie ja so toll damit
umgehen kann mit dem programm da würde
ich sie erlauben ihnen bald ganz kurz
ein zitat aus einer pressemitteilung des
gdw vorhalten der gdw ist ja bekanntlich
sehr habe der verband die sozusagen die
aus ihrer sicht zu sein die guten
wohnungsunternehmen die sozial
aufgestellten wohnungsunternehmen
vertreten und dann will ich das zitat
nochmal vorhalten dort wird formuliert
dringender denn je ist das voerder chaos
beim klima schonenden bezahlbaren bauen
zu wenden planbarkeit vun voraussetzung
für das entstehen von neuen wohnraum
dafür ist eine wirksame verlässliche
fördert systematik dringend notwendig
das fiasko rund um die fifa hat jetzt
schon verzögerung von bis zu zwölf
monaten bei bau und monetisierung
verursacht die nicht mehr aufzuholen
sind wenn man wenn man so etwas jetzt
hört dann ist da noch ein gewisser
widerspruch zu dem was sie sagen dass
die bauwirtschaft so toll damit umgehen
kann richtig ist es doch dass wir morgen
einen riesigen agent ismus haben dass
zwei drittel der projekte momentan
zurückgestellt werden bei keiner genau
weiß was denn eigentlich die
förderbedingungen ab 11 20 23 sein und
da würde ich mich schon mal
interessieren wie sie diesen widerspruch
eigentlich auflösen wollen genau also
tatsächlich erstmalig differenzieren
zwischen bau- und wohnungswirtschaft
also erstmals ist total gut möglich
klimaeffizienz auf den kfw 40 standard
zu bauen und das nächste problem ist
total war der gdw sagt etwas völlig war
es aber das förderkreis das haben wir ja
nicht verursacht
ich bin fahre angefallen wohnungs und
bau politik hier im bundestag zu machen
das erste was ich getan hat war eine
unfassbare krisenkommunikation weil über
zehn milliarden euro in ein völlig
überfordertes programm gesteckt worden
und wir einfach als haushalt lieber denn
dieses parlament bestimmt den haushalt
kein geld
so und das ist deswegen hat minister
alten na ja das haben meine kollegen
schon mehrfach gesagt während er noch
regiert hat dieses förderprogramm
gestoppt es hatte keine steuersenkung
mehr es hat
wahnsinnig viel steuergeld verschlungen
und es hat ganz bestimmt nicht die
wirkung gehabt eigenheim zu fördern hin
und wieder sicherlich mal aber es ist
eine subvention der wohnungswirtschaft
gewesen ist in ordnung aber sie haben
das bundesförderprogramm für effiziente
gebäude dafür zweckentfremdet herr
dokter löschen
wir machen das ja auch ich glaube das
haben alle meine vorrednerin schon
gesagt dass die ampel koalition
eigentumsbildung ist uns wichtig wir
werden aber die förderung einmal
komplett auf neue füße stellen müssen
denn das was wir von ihnen übernommen
haben das reicht einfach nicht
wir wollen das 1,5 grad ziel halten das
sind wir der generation die dort oben
sitzt verpflichtet denn der klimawandel
bedroht ganz konkret den traum vom
altenheim das wissen alle die im
rheinland pfalz oder nordrhein-westfalen
von dem schlimmen hochwasser betroffen
waren im letzten jahr die haben ihr
eigenheim ihre erinnerungen ihre
rentenvorsorge all das haben sie verlor
und durch den klimawandel deswegen ist
es wichtig dass die bundesförderung für
effiziente gebäude in zukunft effizient
zu gebäude fördert nicht nur den neuen
berlin
und das ist gut dass wir das jetzt
machen wir stellen die bundesförderung
für effiziente gebäude neu auf der
machten eine richtlinie für förderung
von pilotprojekten der seriellen saniert
und wir machen eine bundesförderung für
wärmenetze wir machen ein gesetz zur
kommunalen wer mit planen und wir machen
ein aufbauprogramm mit qualifikations
offensive für wärmepumpe und dann klappt
das auch mit dem klimafreundlichen
unruhen wurden das ist aber nicht nur
aus bezahlbarkeit kunden wichtig das ist
eben auch wichtig weil wir gerade eine
große geopolitische abhängigkeit haben
vor explodierenden gaspreisen wurde
immer wieder gewarnt vor der hohen
abhängigkeit von putins gas im
wohnbereich wurde immer wieder gewarnt
und dank ihres nicht handeln werden wir
bis 2030 permanent klimaziele reißen
selbst wenn wir alle ressourcen die wir
haben jetzt in effizienz stoff förderung
von gebäuden stecken
wir wollen eigentlich fördern das ist
uns wichtig und ich finde es sehr selbst
dass der finanzminister gerade mit den
ländern bezüglich der grunderwerbssteuer
verhandelt und wir wollen eine neue
eigenkapital förderung auflegen und das
genossenschafts programm ich glaube
damit haben wir schon die ersten
grundsteine gelegt was wir tun müssen
ist die bodenpreise senken denn das
macht wohnen neben der inflation und dem
baustoff mangel extrem teuer und die
wir müssen scherzt in tabletten und wir
müssen kommunen dazu befähigen das eben
boden vor bevorratung betreiben können
und wir müssen uns mal die
maklercourtage angucken in anderen
ländern sind das so 2% in wer bestellt
bezahlt
in deutschland ist sie gestiegen seit
des gesetzes was die groko 2000
abgeschlossen so von 6 auf gut 7 prozent
das muss man sich mal vorstellen
das sind die üblichen erwerbs kreisen
30.000 euro das ist ein wunderschönes
eigenkapital welches wir reguliert
dringend regulieren sollten liebe union
wir kümmern uns jetzt dass das klappt
mit dem klimafreundlichen wohnen wir
kümmern uns jetzt dass es klappt mit der
eigentumsförderung und wir kümmern uns
jetzt dass es klappt das die energie
preise sinken ich glaube das haben wir
ein großes programm mit dem wir
zusammenarbeiten
christina johanna schröder war das für
bündnis 90 die grünen hier in der
debatte wie
wohneigentum gefördert werden kann
nächster redner ist aus der
unionsfraktion hier auch den antrag
eingereicht hat
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
verehrte frau ministerin es muss ja
einen unterschied machen wie der kollege
fürst gesagt hat ob man ein ministerium
hat oder nicht hat deswegen
respektieren wir dass sie sich der
heutigen debatte stellen ich sage ihnen
aber auch ganz offen all die bauwilligen
hätten auch ihren respekt verdient
gehabt in den letzten wochen und monaten
bevor dieses chaos ausgebrochen ist
vergangenen mittwoch hat das
statistische bundesamt die neuen zahlen
gemeldet minus 8,9 prozent weniger
genehmigungen für neue wohnungen
neubauten und umbauten
minus
26,2 prozent im vergleich zum
vorjahresmonat bei einfamilienhäusern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen minus
26,2 prozent dh hier sind die geplatzten
träume die sie zu verantworten haben
und das liegt an der verkürzten
förderpolitik und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der spd ich frage natürlich wo
war die bauer ministerin beim
förderstopp diese frage muss erlaubt
sein denn wer war denn der
finanzminister der das programm
hinterlegt hat das war olaf polster
bundeskanzler hätte jetzt ein machtwort
sprechen können für ein programm das wir
gemeinsam aufgesetzt haben das haben wir
nicht getan hat er gezögert und
gezaudert und es kam nichts lieber
kollege der druck des wegen eklatanter
vertrauensbruch und wütende
protestschreiben der menschen aus all
unseren wahlkreisen die einfach bitter
enttäuscht wurden von der neuen
regierung und liebe ministerin ich
zitiere sie richtig ökonomisch und
ökologisch unsinnig wenn jede generation
neue einfamilienhäuser baut ja aber
minus 26,2 prozent kann nicht unsinnig
sein wenn ich mir anschaue wie groß die
lücke ist am neuen wohnungen an
einfamilienhäusern denn so werden wir
auch das problem steigender mieten nicht
in den griff bekommen wenn weniger
gebaut wird werden die mieten definitiv
nicht sinken liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und wenn sie dann auch nicht
energieeffizient bauen wird auch nicht
funktionieren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der grünen sie können doch kein
interesse daran haben dass die menschen
nicht mal mehr standard 55 bauen weil
sie sich nicht leisten können sie bauen
noch weniger dass es doch nicht ihre
politik dass es doch nicht ihr anspruch
sie scheitern in den ersten tagen schon
an sich selber das ist nicht sozial und
nicht ökologisch was sie uns bisher hier
vorgelegt habe
der traum vom eigenheim schutz vor
altersarmut der traum vom eigenheim ist
familienpolitik
75 prozent derer die bei kindergeld
bezogen haben haben ein einkommen von
weniger als 60.000 euro
35 jahre war das durchschnittsalter der
antragsteller
1,7 kinder
400.000 anträge
710000 kinder haben ein eigenes dach
über den kopf bekommen das ist union das
ist familienpolitik und deren
fortsetzung erwarten wir auch von der
ampel mit planungssicherheit mit den
förderprogrammen damit die menschen
wieder sich darauf verlassen können was
regierungen was der deutsche bundestag
beschließt sie haben einen anspruch auf
ein ende dieses hauses machen sie weiter
endlich mit dem brachflächen programm
das hilft gegen die bodenpreise da haben
sie da haben sie liebe kollegin aldrup
in der letzten periode
gebremst sie waren der bremse an diese
stelle
neubauförderung sitzungsschluss regen
statt menschen träumen weiter von ihren
eigenen vier wänden herzlichen dank
ulrich lange kriegt hier viel applaus
von seiner fraktion
für diese rede und immer sehen wie das
beim nächsten redner aussieht ist es der
letzte reden bevor hier die abgeordneten
abstimmen timon gremmels für die
spd-fraktion
kollegen ich bin richtig froh das ist
die andere träume aber als friedrich
merz in die cdu csu fraktion
also ich meine wählerinnen und wähler
sie träumen von bezahlbaren wohnen das
ist ganz raum der mehrheit dieser
menschen und bezahlbare wohnung
inkludiert fast natürlich auch im
einzelfall das eigenheim was man selber
bauen möchte aber ehrlich gesagt wenn es
ihnen um die sache gegangen wäre wenn
sie ordentlich auch eine revision
gemacht hätten was sie die letzten 16
jahre getan oder eben nicht getan hätten
wenn sie sich in der sache korrigieren
und verbessern wollen dann hätte ich mir
bei anderen antrag gewünschten dass sie
jetzt wirklich nötig haben sind entsteht
zu zitieren und damit ihren antrag
einzubringen das hat ja in die minister
hier schon deutlich gemacht das ist
etwas wofür sie sich schämen sollten
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
dass sie so etwas nötig so hat kennen
wir eigentlich nur vom brems rechten
zeit
und ich bin ehrlich froh dass wir eine
eigene bau ministerin haben oder eben
das nicht mehr ein alex ist ans
innenministerium wie das unter horst
seehofer aber der fall war wir haben
dafür gesagt dass dieses thema auf
gewertet wird das wäre ein eigenes haus
haben dass wir eine engagierte
ministerin haben die ideen und konzepte
hier vorstellt auf die wir unter
seehofer vier jahre lang gewartet haben
und nicht nur wir sondern den menschen
in diesem land und sich dann jetzt hier
hinzustellen und noch geschichts
revision zu betreiben wer hat denn im
november letzten jahres dieses kfw
förderprogramm zum 31 erst diesen jahres
auslaufen lassen er war als minister
kein wort nicht einmal ist der name
peter altmaier von ihnen gefallen hat
wird vier redner haben wir gesprochen
nach zehn minuten haben sie geredet sie
haben weder über den bauminister horst
seehofer gesprochen noch über den für
das gebäude energiegesetz zuständigen
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier sie
haben ihre eigene ihre eigenen minister
sozusagen hier und diesen teil der
geschichte überhaupt nicht im blick
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und der damen dann frage ich sie was er
hat denn horst seehofer gemacht um die
800.000 bau überhänge kurzfristig
abzuarbeiten was war denn das was sie da
geliefert haben nichts und nach zu einer
ordentlichen aufarbeitung die eigene
regierungsverantwortung gehört auch die
kritische selbst befassung und ich gebe
ihnen dazu das ist ein kommunikatives
nicht die gerade die glanzleistung war
mit dem kfw programmen gar keine frage
wir haben da auch vertrauen verspielt
aber dass eine gemeinschaftliche
verantwortung und da haben die sich
entzog meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren ii geht es hier nicht um die
sache geht es hier um billige
oppositionspolitik und das ehrlich
gesagt ist aus meiner sicht zu wenig wir
beschäftigen und umfassend mit dieser
thematik und wir gucken dass wir nach
vorne blicken und ich sage ihnen mal was
aus meinem eigenen war kreis wenn ich
bei mir im ländlichen raum unterwegs bin
habe ich folgendes phänomen die
ortskerne der dörfer bluten aus weil die
häuser zu klein sind weil sie nicht mehr
den ansprüchen von heute genügen bei
teilweise denkmalschutzauflagen da sind
und an den ortsrändern sollen neue
baugebiete entstehen wir müssen doch
gucken dass wir auch die ortskerne
stärken dass wir programme entwickeln
wie man auch im dorfkern gut und modern
und sicher leben kann wie man
energetisch sanieren kann wie man auch
gucken dass wir die menschen dorthin
bringen und nicht immer aus frauen sind
weitere neue wohngebiete haben meine
sehr verehrten damen und darum müssen
wir uns kümmern und deswegen müssen wir
uns in der tat wieder angebote schaffen
und was ich noch erleben werde ich bei
mir im ort unterwegs bin dass ganz viele
mittlerweile ältere ehepaare oder auch
witwen und witwer in den ganz großen
häusern alleine leben weil es eben keine
kleinen wohnung gibt die sich auch nicht
mehr kaufen wollen die mieten wollen und
dann und stanz bauten frei machen würden
die familien darüber müssen wir uns und
darum müssen wir uns kümmern auch das
ist ein traum den die menschen haben die
sehr verehrten damen und herren davon
ist in ihrem antrag äußerst wenig zu
lesen und dann müssen wir gucken dass
wir auch all das was wir tun in der tat
so tun dass wir hier als
energieeffizient machen ist hilft doch
jetzt nicht schnell und preiswert zu
bauen und dann die folgekosten die
energiekosten von morgen sind die
menschen genauso belasten wir haben
kredite bezahlen müssen auch darum
müssen wir uns kümmern auch da reden wir
viel zu wenig von ihnen und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass diese koalition sich zum
ziel gesetzt hat mehr zu bauen bezahlbar
zu bauen dass wir 400.000 neue wohnungen
schaffen als wir es gemeinschaftlich
machen und dass wir das nachhaltig
machen dafür stehen wir bereit dafür
steht die opposition da werden wir auch
liefern diesen senat ist gut
ich schließe die debatte
zusatzpunkt fünf interfraktionell wird
überweisungen der vorlage auf drucksache
18 55 an die in der tagesordnung
aufgeführten ausschüsse vorgeschlagen
gibt es weitere überweisungs vorschläge
dass es nicht der fall dann verfahren
wir wie vorgeschlagen
tagesordnungspunkt 30 wir kommen nun zur
abstimmung über die beschlussempfehlung
des ausschusses für klimaschutz und
energie zu dem entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen der cdu/csu zu der abgabe
einer regierungserklärung durch den
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz zu dem thema für eine sozial
ökologische marktwirtschaft
transformation innovativ gestalten
jahreswirtschaftsbericht
2022 der ausschuss empfiehlt in seiner
beschlussempfehlung auf drucksache 18 35
den entschließungsantrag der fraktionen
der cdu/csu auf drucksache
524 abzulehnen auf verlangen der
fraktionen der cdu/csu stimmen wir über
die beschlussempfehlung
namentlich ab es liegt eine erklärung
zur abstimmung nach § 31 unserer
geschäftsordnung vor die abstimmung
erfolgt in der west lobby sie haben zur
abgabe ihrer stimme 20 minuten zeit die
schriftführerin und schriftführer sind
bereits an ihren plätzen dann eröffnet
so also die abstimmung wird eröffnet in
diesem antrag fordert die union unter
anderem dass eben dieser förderstopp der
ja auch diskutiert würde wieder sofort
rückgängig gemacht wird und die
abgeordneten werden jetzt also in der
west- floridas ist außerhalb des
plenarsaals hier abstimmen dieses
verfahren hat sich in der pandemie hier
eingebürgert um abstand halten zu können
wären dann ab
der nächste tagesordnungspunkt
beschäftigt sich mit einem
bundeswehreinsatz schon seit
1978 überwachung un-blauhelmsoldaten das
grenzgebiet zwischen dem libanon und
israel das war eigentlich als
übergangslösung geplant aber diesen
einsatz uni viel gibt es immer noch dass
es kurz für united nations interim force
in lebanon und die bundeswehr beteiligt
sich mit bis zu 300 soldaten laut mandat